[Music]
well hey what's going on you guys times
like a can I put my costume on now is it
ready yeah so there he is he's being
that looks really good I think that
looks really good
yeah yeah that's his that's his Bain
outfit that he's going to wear to the
party tomorrow
night I'm assuming you're going to wear
that cuz you've been working on that for
a long time yeah cuz he made that uh
that arm thing
yeah and you also made you didn't make
the mask but you altered The Mask like
you bought one and then like you it
didn't fit right it didn't fit right
it's still not really perfect but it
kind of there's a space that goes
through here yeah you can't get it to
fit I don't say it looks cool though but
know I got
got a radio I thought you were going to
take your pants off for a second radio
don't tease me like
that pistol mags yeah there you
go yeah it's cool looking I think and he
also has like you have like a vest thing
that you could wear yeah but it's not
the correct one I didn't want I wanted
the re I wanted to make the real
bulletproof vest right that he had
because I can get the material to make
it like threat level three
bistic resistant I could do it so it
wouldn't have cost much more to make a
real bulletproof vest so I actually
thought about doing it but the money and
the time you know that's what I mean
it's like I always come up with all
these ideas because remember last year I
was like oh I'm going to do like this
whole werewolf thing or I'm going to be
like lady predator or something like
that but it's just like I ran out of
time I ran out of money I just couldn't
afford to get anything so now I'm just
like scrambling I'm just like well [__]
now I'm going to have to like do
something that I've already done that I
already have the stuff for for like
because I like I can't afford to buy
anything else so it's just so I don't
know so I'm kind of trying to think
about it cuz I was wait before the show
we were cuz mannequins is doing a
classic monsters party tonight and I
said and I do have a Bride of
Frankenstein get up because I wore that
two or three years ago um so you know I
could do that but it's like I don't have
time to do it before we go tonight cuz
that the makeup takes a while but and
I'd have to like and I I don't know if I
could tease my I guess I could tease my
own hair although I also have a black
wig an old black wig I could probably
tease as well but um so I don't know I
don't know if I'm going to do that or
like I said I was Medusa last year that
costume did kick ass though and um I
said the only other one that I have I
think three years ago I was vampire Amy
from Fright Night you know the original
Fright Night from 1985 and I still have
all the stuff for that except maybe the
contact lenses I'm not sure where I put
those yellow and red contact lenses I'm
sure they're around here somewhere but
yeah so we decided that like cuz I think
Tom wanted to go to mannequins tonight
but I was like there's just no way I
could get ready or like think of
anything in time and um it' probably be
a [__] show in a mad house anyway it'll
be like super crowded so Barbarella is
doing a Halloween party tomorrow
night um and they're having a costume
contest and stuff like that so that'll
be better because I could have more time
to come up with something like I said
I'll probably just end up wearing
something maybe I'll do vampire Amy
again because I don't
remember did I don't even think I went
out in that
costume I think I wore I wore it three I
think it was three years ago because we
were still at the old house yeah I think
I wore it on the
show and you know gave out candy and
stuff like that but I don't think we
went out in it not that I remember
anyway then do that one so maybe I
should do that one I still got the wig I
still got the dress the makeup takes a
while because you have to do like you
know the big mouth and everything so I'd
have to give myself some time to do that
but maybe I'll do
that so I mean you know and that would
probably like go well too because
Barbarella that's you know Saturday
that's that's her 80s night 80s movie so
maybe that's what I'll do and it's been
a long time since I've done that I mean
you guys probably remember it but I
don't think I went anywhere in it Bride
of Frankenstein and Medusa I went to
mannequins in those outfits big Little's
going to mannequins tonight too he
always does okay yeah he always does
yeah yeah what's up Dave yeah yeah tell
me uh how the costumes are tell me if
it's crowded or a big [__] show or
everything like that because we were
thinking I'm like if if we went tonight
I wouldn't have time to do a costume so
you know cuz I just didn't have time but
you know what I
mean Lim Lee says hello I just watch
shorts
Pooky we only have one short on here and
it is a poooky I think she's like
sleeping on my laptop or something like
that uh Dave said your Medusa was hot I
love how my Medusa outfit came out I
worked really hard on that and I thought
it came out like super [__] cool I
thought it looked really good I wish I'd
gotten some I got some decent pictures
of it but I wish I'd have gotten like
better pictures of it because when I was
at mannequins last year man everybody
came up and told me how cool it
was yeah Lim was just uh asking what I'm
going to dress up as that's what I was
just trying that's what I was just
trying to side now Tom was Bane last
year too but you were like the comic
book Bane like with the El Santo style
like a wrestler like the wrestler kind
of thing yeah he was the comic book
version yeah black the black and red one
black red and white so now that I think
about it I probably will do Fright Night
Amy like vampire Amy mhm cuz that and I
could probably do what ended up
happening when I did it the first time
which I'm pretty sure was three years
ago is you know if you've seen Fright
Night you know the Tom Holland one from
1985 like she has that big huge mouth
that's like way out here with like all
his [__] teeth and it's like really
really cool looking and initially I had
bought this vampire mask like a whole
mask and I had cut the mouth part out
because it was this big wide mouth and I
was trying to put it on with latex and
it looks kind of cool but I couldn't
really get it to stay and I couldn't get
to like match my skin and everything
like that so I was like well this is a
pain in the ass so I just threw it out
and then I just drew it on like with
paint and like makeup and stuff and it
looked okay but I I think if I had more
time I could do like a better job you
know what I mean cuz I was kind of
rushing so maybe I'll try try and do an
improvement on
it so and I don't think anyone has seen
that one okay uh L said you should bring
Pooky to the live show she might come by
yeah it's weird because Bambi was in
here earlier little Bambi Dakota Miz
underfoot as I call her um she was in
here earlier but she doesn't ever seem
cuz I was like I think you guys have
only seen her one time right like right
after maybe the day or two after we
adopted her I can go get her like I
think Tom picked her up and put her on
the show so we could like introduce her
to everybody cuz she's our you know
newest baby we've only had her for a few
months she seems to have adapted
well but uh but she never seems to be
around she doesn't seem interested in
the show you know what I mean so she's
never around like to put her on the show
but Pooky is usually in here because
she's like what are you guys doing why
are you not paying attention to me
whenever you're doing anything she has
to get involved you know what I'm saying
she just follows us around everywhere
although Bambi does that too but usually
when she wants
food you
know yeah Pooky shows up when she feels
like
it yeah Danny ring said I never saw her
yet yeah I think the I think we've only
shown her one time and it's like maybe
the day after we adopted her because we
talked about and I think we talked about
adopting her like on our Meg review or
Meg 2 review that got taken down for a
little while because of copyright blah
blah blah and um it it's been reinstated
now but I think that's when we were
talking about it because that was the
day that we had adopted her when we went
to see that movie cuz we got her from
the
PetSmart Oracle said I was at the
PetSmart the other day and the adoption
center had this lovely blueo Siamese
kitty named Luna a she's been there a
couple weeks and I keep wanting to adopt
her it's like oh it makes me so sad like
whenever I I want to go in and look at
the kitties but then I'm like I don't
want to because then I'm just going to
want to take them all what happens too
is that sometimes cuz a lot of times we
go to the um oh he's got her yeah he's
got her what you doing bamb hey it's
okay she's like oh my God what is
happening right
now it's okay see she's so pretty she
looks like a little Bob she looks like a
little bobcat bobcat yeah and she's a MX
too so she has a longer tail than po
though but it's only like halfway she
trying to get down she doesn't know
about being on the screen she's like
what is happening right now you're on TV
it's just me it's Mommy it's okay she's
like I'm out of here she's like I don't
know I'm very
nervous but she didn't go anywhere she
just stayed there and looked at me yeah
she's over there now yeah she's under
the table what you
doing but yeah so we go to the books of
million there in the same Mall as the
petmart and every what they say it was
like every week or every other week they
have a k adoption event so the people
from hoffm animal shelter which is where
she came from they came they come over
and they set up in the cafe so there's
like little kittens everywhere and
everybody like there's so there's
millions of people in there like petting
the kitties and I think she's I think
she's uh 18 months is she they're asking
how old yeah yeah she's a year and a
half old yeah and they told us we didn't
know this when we adopted her but we
she's jumping um but they told oh [__]
chasing they're chasing each other um
they told us when we ad like later on
when we asked about her that um that
she'd already had a litter and I think I
think they implied that that was why the
people who had her gave her away because
she'd had babies like she went out and
got
pregnant and then had babies and they
were like yeah we we don't want to put
up with that so they surrendered her
yeah lmy said you got another cat yes
yes we did so we have three now we still
have beang um who is 13 14 she's old
yeah 14 years old y um she does she
comes upstairs every now and then but
she mostly hangs out downstairs yeah
she's real chilled out now she's old she
just kind of likes to sleep on the back
of the couch and be pretty yeah so she
doesn't come up here much she Ms out she
yells at you when you walk
by
okay she bad about something I don't
know
[__] a little bit Yeah you go P her
and then she okay all right yeah but we
were talking about it the other day
because uh Pooky and Bambi have very
very different personalities I think
it's because Pooky was raised by people
she hasn't really been around other cats
other than Beijing um and she's not real
big big on Beijing either she doesn't
care about Beijing yeah not really
they're not friends so um I mean Pooky
is just I think she thinks she's a tiny
fuzzy person like she acts like a little
person you know there's Pooky right here
just talking about you come here P come
here she's like what okay yeah but the
thing about Bambi is I think since she
grew up in a they poke since she grew up
in an environment just surrounded by
other cats she's much more cat-like
whereas Pooky is much more personlike or
like a dog almost or yeah I mean Pooky
know a dog and a monkey she knows her
name she understands like a whole bunch
of words like in commands and stuff yeah
um you know whereas Bambi like I was
calling Bambi the other day day and she
was just like completely ignoring me
like she didn't even know I was talking
to her PS has a bunch of rituals too
yeah she has to do certain things at
certain times yeah she demands certain
things at certain times certain kind you
know certain like meat sticks treats she
knows what time she gets those and
everything's on a schedule yeah as soon
as we kind of like she keeps the
schedule for me okay it's this time oh
yeah okay it's wrestling time now yeah
right yeah time for her daddy to wrestle
yeah wrestling is first when I first
wake up yeah
yeah cuz he gets his cup of coffee and
he sits on the thing at the end of the
bed like the bench turn on some YouTube
she starts wrestle she [__] and rolls
over
yeah wrestling time yeah that goes on
for about 15 minutes he's got to let
play with her like before and then like
when we in the evenings like when we go
and kind of like settle in to like watch
a movie or something like that she just
she kind of comes in like that like with
that weird little butt shaking run that
she has and she comes in right next to
the right next to the the uh the bedside
table where the meat sticks are like in
the drawer and she just like plops her
little butt down and looks up at daddy
with his big like eyes like meet sck
time please and then you have to sit
there and hold it you have to hold it in
your hand while she well she doesn't eat
it at first she licks it well she chews
it first and then she gets about halfway
and then she just lick and then she just
likes licking it licking a little stuff
and then if you if you go no I don't
have time for this to put it down she
goes and if you drop it she's like [__]
you and then she runs out of the room
you [__] frustrated
[__] or she'll start tearing the carpet
up like yeah yeah yeah that wasn't what
I wanted yeah she gets frustrated it's
like hilarious but yeah you have to do
it like that you have to hold it and
it's like well you can't hold it the
whole time because she'll bite your
finger off you know what I mean so it's
like you try to hold it but then
eventually you're just going to drop it
and then she's going to get upset so I I
don't know what she expects but that's
kind of what she
does H yeah Oracle said it's hard to um
I talking about the
kitties oh Oracle said the sticking
point is my kitty Ash is 17 years old
and he doesn't want to share yeah I mean
yeah I mean when kitties are that age
they get kind of set in their ways oh
poop no don't bite shoes oh she blew me
off she goes no I do what I want she's
like I do what I want don't do it she's
like I can chew other things what's the
do yeah see I don't think she
understands like yeah she loves to bite
shoes chew up shoes yeah she loves shoes
well I think that's whole reason she
wants to go in the closet all the time
yeah Che was in there and she thinks you
can't hear her which is hilarious if Tom
leaves his boots out at like the end of
the bed and like we're sitting up on the
bed and you can't really see it and but
you'll
hear Pokey and then she runs around the
corner like I was I wasn't doing
anything
look leave the boots Alone come
here no
no yeah you can chew on you can chew on
other
things
yeah she's upset yeah or she keeps
seeing them and they're right at the
perfect angle at the perfect angle to go
up and
go man it's hilarious because I have
like all those like big like Spike heel
like [__] shoes that I wear sometimes on
streammate and if I sit there that's
what she's that's what she's okay so
that's just she's trying to go right
there oh that's just my regular sandal
yeah but it's like if I have a pair of
those on like the spike heels and I'll
be sitting there you know on the stream
or whatever with my legs crossed and
then Pooky will come up and just start
chewing on the on the spike heel
hilarious oh yeah and she loves to chew
on those she loves those yeah she loves
to chew on those so if I wear those I
have to be really careful because she'll
be like oh she'll just come right over
and go it was this one it was that one
yeah yeah yeah she likes that one too
yeah yeah she you probably see little
tooth marks and if you look close enough
hey ganthers is here where have you been
I haven't seen him in a while did you
hear what I said yeah oh okay he didn't
answer so I wasn't sure no I heard yeah
yeah uh Grand said How's married life
going for you crazy kids any any
different than Prem married life no it's
not I mean like I said we've been
together such a long time that it really
didn't uh make much of a difference just
got to remember what our anniversary day
is you remembered it yeah of course I
remember I'm a girl yeah girls remember
all that [__] September 14th yeah if I
forget it I'll be in the dog house
that's right
yeah you're going to be he doesn't
remember my birthday no I I sometimes
forget my birthday that's true and how
old I am
and I always have to remind him multiple
times but yeah it was September 14th so
I 12 days before my birthday so um
Allison says Jenny and Tom you have
different drinks from each other tonight
what you got um well mine is vodka and
this is fruit wait grape juice is it
grape juice couldn't see it was kind of
dark grape juice okay it either grape
juice or fruit punch but what's that
what's that one
uh what's in here saw something flying
in here it's a little like gnat or
something okay
um it was passion fruit oh where'd that
come from I bought it oh remember we got
it got it at Sam's two for
$5 not Sam's Publix I mean Publix yeah
yeah yeah cuz I was like I haven't been
to Sam in a long time it see I couldn't
see like both the cartons look the same
so I was just like whichever one this is
I don't know so in the glass okay yeah
yeah well that was the thing they only
had they were two for
$5 and then but they only had one of the
like other fruity flavors like passion
fruit or whatever the hell that is and
then all the other ones were grape and I
was like well it's not ideal but you
know vodka goes with everything that's
why vodka is good you can just put it
with any kind of juice and it's
delicious a oracle's talking about and
her cat said her cat looks like Pooky
except with the longer tail said I first
met Ash when he was a weak old cuz his
mama was rescued by a friend of ours so
I've been his person forever yeah I
think if you when you raise them from
real little like that I mean there's
just some kind
of you know cuz like I said I think it's
kind of so that I think that's why it's
different like interacting with Bambi
because you know she grew up and had a
litter of kittens like still young but
you know before we met her and she's
grew up in kind of a shelter so she's
been around other cats and stuff so
she's not as personlike I guess as Pooky
is Allison says she's drinking triple
second vodka that also sounds good yeah
I think there might be a name for that I
forgot what that was Triple second vodka
and OJ
yeah there must be a name for that
there's a name for everything there's a
name for everything yeah for every
single combination all right so
um now that we've talked about
cats Jen and I were going through the
damn Batman animated
movie uh uh selection I feel like such
an [__] because when you guys said
Gotham by Gaslight and um the Doom that
came to Gotham and we paid to rent both
of those on Amazon Prime and then we
went over to HBO max they're for free
and they're on there for free cuz I have
HBO Max through my phone plan and I was
like well sorry so you just paid like
[__] six bucks six bucks that you
didn't have to pay for but oh well
didn't have to put up with commercials
they had like HBO Max has a [__] ton of
the animated DC stuff like I was we were
just going through there going holy crap
yeah they had so much and we we sampled
two of them and we I didn't like them
couldn't get into them first one was uh
uh the long Halloween we started
watching the long Halloween part one and
I just couldn't get into it yeah I
couldn't get didn't like the acting
didn't like the way it was animated or
edited or anything so discontinued that
one then went to Batman year One we got
through about 20 minutes of that and I
was like nah this isn't for me so then
we went to
um n ninja Batman Ninja Batman yeah
ninja Batman was very good okay that was
cool I think when all talked about that
fell asleep at the end I did I was
really tired I turned it off and we're
going to have to finish the end of it
but it was pretty good and it was
about one of the bad guys he's some
gorilla talking gorilla I forgot what
his name gorilla grod gorilla grod yeah
he makes a time machine and Batman tries
to stop him like gorillas do yeah
gorilla grod had all the bad guys there
and they got they got [__] up they got
the time machine blew up or something it
malfunctioned and they all got sent back
into fudal Japan but they arrived at
different times when Batman arrived the
other ones had been there for
years and U the bad guys and they had
they had taken over Japan they had whole
feudal armies they were in the Waring
States periods and everything and Batman
has to stop them it's pretty good and
the animation is gorgeous yeah it's more
like computer animation though it's like
a video game but you can't tell it's
video it's cool looking though like the
style of it is really cool so yeah Joker
and Harley Quinn are kind of like the
main baddies yeah yeah and all the
female characters all have [__]
outstanding boobs the the artists are
Japanese the director's Japanese the you
know that's J yeah and it and it's done
anime
style was good yeah I mean I really I
really liked it like I said I did I just
cuz I fell asleep that's no ding on it
it's just I I was up really really early
so yeah Batman gets adopt Batman loses
all his technology fighting him and uh
he thinks he's going to lose when he
gets adopted by the the ninja clan that
was waiting for him he was part of their
prophecy so he becomes a ninja yeah so
Batman a ninja he's running a whole Army
of
Ninjas
I mean yeah it's it's pure bullido
that's kind of what I liked about it
yeah oh yeah they lean into the
bullshito Batman saying yeah Ninjutsu is
even better than all the toys that I had
back in Gotham City
you probably not but you know what I
mean and uh what was really cool about
it is that all the uh the Batman
villains they had been there long enough
where all their castles could convert
into giant Mecca giant robots they were
fighting each cuz it's Japan man yeah
you can't just have like a pagota or
nothing like that it's like no it's got
to turn into a giant robot also yeah
yeah because of course it does yeah
Batman has to fight giant robots cuz
like well yeah well it's like Joker had
one and then it's like this big [__]
mechanized arm comes out and we were
like oh of course right yeah yeah that's
the way we're like not even surprised
that's the way they're going to go yeah
not even surprised so it's just ghost to
but I'm still going to say like of all
the ones that we've watched I know that
we didn't finish long Halloween and we
didn't finish year one cuz like I said I
just couldn't get into it I was hoping
the long Halloween would be more like
Halloweeny but it was kind of more like
a Godfather type like a gangster type
which yeah so I couldn't really get into
it as much um which maybe it's good I
don't know maybe it gets better because
it's long it's like [__] what is it
three hours or something yeah well the
voice acting I didn't think that was
that good yeah that's true and I didn't
like the animation as much but I'm going
to say like out of all of the ones that
we've watched recently I mean goth by
gas L is easily my favorite one I mean I
thought that was excellent and then U
the Doom that came to Gotham was pretty
great too it's pretty good but I think
I'd put I think I'd put dra uh Batman
versus Dracula above the uh the
Lovecraft one yeah just for the
story I mean I don't know it's just more
like a you Batman versus dracul it's
more like a Batman story more like a
superhero story yeah like you were
saying the Lovecraft one was like very
obviously a Lovecraft story that just
happened Batman in it yeah it wasn't
quite as satisfying for me right and it
was a
little I think if you if you're not real
up on your Lovecraft lore it might have
been a little bit hard to follow maybe
I'm not really sure kind of a convoluted
story to me well it because it was kind
of a combination of a bunch of different
Lovecraft stories like they were kind of
wve them all in there I say Gotham by
Gaslight and then Batman versus Dracula
yeah yeah even though they're very
different the Dracula one was good too
because it's like I really really liked
the Dracula character I like Peter stor
a ninja Batman's easily in the two in
the top
three yeah I mean the look of that was
like super [__] cool it was easy to
follow too you knew what they're doing
yeah it's a Japanese style Batman yeah
it's just like anime style they're doing
montages and introductions every time
something happens it now says you know
super powerful mechanized Batman just
just like names come up on there pretty
cool and you
know Japanese artists always draw
Western women [__] to amazing in
proportions so it looks pretty cool well
they're like yeah might as well you can
draw however you want C kind of Catwoman
was stacked poison ivy stacked Harley
Quinn stacked they're doing [__] back
flips through the
air hitting the ground perfectly [__]
it's just it you know male gays man lots
and lots of male gays it's real fast too
you have really time for anything yeah
um boobies yeah Joker you the voice
acting for the Joker I didn't like it
that much but it was yeah it's a little
I was going to say it's a little over
the top even though D that's the whole
point of the character but I mean even
by those standards I think it was a
little bit over the top but it was still
pretty good though but I like the look
of the character the character design
yeah he looks good Danny Rowling said
the Son of Batman animated movie is
really good with his blood son Damen
Wayne yeah I think that one was on there
too because that was one of the ones I
couldn't like I said I could not believe
I was like [__] man here's the thing
about nowadays here's the thing about
nowadays is that even if you just
like Batman or even if you like DC or
even if you just like Batman there is so
much [__] Batman content it's like
you probably wouldn't live long enough
to like watch all of the [__] and like
read all the graphic novels and
everything like that and that's just one
tiny little intellectual property oh no
you put your mind to it you can watch
all that you probably qu but yeah but
then like what about all like I said
what about all the um you could go
through super graic novels and I don't
know I don't know they got guys to go
through all that [__] they'll watch all
the Superman stuff they'll watch you
know then the Justice League and some of
that stuff I want to check it out yeah I
do too yeah cuz they have like a bunch
of other like DC B Happ to be in it like
justice league and [__] yeah and I mean
because I because I was sitting there
thinking to myself because I'm looking
at this huge list of like all these
[__] animated Batman movies and I'm
just like there's some Batman LEGO
movies that usually the Lego movies are
kind of fun I actually I lik I've liked
the Lego movies that I've seen are super
cute and like I did kind of want to see
that Batman Lego Movie I think I'm
pretty sure that's on HBO Max too but um
I think there's two of them now that I'm
thinking about it but because I was
thinking of myself I was thinking like
somebody like me that's super into like
my main thing is you know other than
horror movies is Mystery Science Theater
and it's like even that I I haven't even
begun to scratch the surface I've seen
all the original episodes like from
their original run but I still haven't
seen like all the new ones um I saw the
ones that they did for Netflix but I
haven't seen the ones that they've done
like you know independently like in the
Gizmo Lex and everything and then also
you have cinematic Titanic and you have
Rift tracks and you have all this other
kind of [__] and it's just so much I'm
just never going to be able to watch it
all
unfortunately but hbm Max and Amazon
Prime do have some of the newer ones
like with Jonah Ray and stuff and I
actually do like those I know a lot of
old school MST people did not like them
because they thought that it was
too um the jokes were too like
fast-paced or it went like you know it's
just different the setup's the same but
it is a little bit different because
it's different people doing the voices
but I did not mind them and some of them
I thought were really funny so you know
I didn't really mind it and then they
have like that other one with that with
the girl host too and I haven't seen
hardly any of those Z just showing up I
got a bunch I got a yeah oh now we're
going to have to do the whole show over
again cuz he just cuz he just got
here did get you do get to see Zach does
get to see the Bane thing so that's why
is that why you put the Bane mask back
on no in a down time after I put the
mask back on okay I'm go get another
drink here in a minute in your downtime
yeah I might need some more oh my
[__] ice melted
yeah yeah Oracle said uh Mark Hamill has
retired from the Joker voice now that
Kevin Conroy has passed I don't blame
him um yeah it's I don't he's kind of
old to do that now he's got he's got of
things going on he was in that series CH
just watch he did he did follow the
house of user yeah he's really good he
was the the Usher family lawyer yeah
yeah that one scene of him like in the
last episode where well I don't want to
spoil it because I know some people
haven't seen it and if I spoil if I say
what he was what the conversation was
about it kind of it's kind of a spoiler
so Mark hell man Star Wars kind of
[__] him up he never really could do
anything after that he was just too
tycast I guess he then ended up in like
playing in the gerver remember that
movie Corvette Summer
was that before Star Wars or after I
think it was right after that might have
been right after yeah I think I saw that
on never really recovered from Star Wars
during the middle part of his career
they
just I guess he couldn't get anything
cool you know he was played out but uh
he's getting good work now he did a lot
of voice acting yeah yeah the voice
acting that was that that's the best
thing he he did that's kind of like the
main thing they said he was like one of
the best Joker voices of all times but I
don't know the series
that was Batman the Animated Series
right he the voice on it yeah yeah so I
you know Zach says how do I get you guys
to go in reverse that's well see that's
the thing about I feel bad for Mark Hill
because he seems like a really nice
person and that's kind of the the
double-edged sword of being in a movie
as massive as Star Wars was in 1977 it's
like now you're this big star and you're
making all this money and everybody
knows who you are but just kind of like
whatever you do after that is just going
to inevitably not be as good and like I
said you might get typ cast into that
type of role and if you can't get those
type of roles no one's going to put you
in anything yeah you know what I mean
and I think for a long time I don't
think this is so much the case nowadays
but I think back then too I think that's
why a lot of actors didn't want to be
like in horror movies for example
because they're like well I don't want
to get typ cast as horror movie guy and
that's like all I'm going to get and I'm
never going to get in these big pres
dramas and win an Oscar or whatever so
cuz horror movies don't win don't win
Oscar that's actually what should have
done probably he should have done
basically what Jeffrey Colmes did yeah
which was horror movies and uh Star Trek
series yeah just weird ass genre [__]
Jeffrey Coles was the [__] in all the
Star Trek [__] that he did as commander
shran and then that Jim Hadar guy think
he did a lot of lot of cool characters
for uh Deep Space 9 and voyage
he was in what was he in the other day
that we saw him and he was just in like
one scene and you were like that's
Jeffrey comes no Jeffree comes did the
voice acting in that Batman animated
that's right Lovecraft movie yeah that's
right that's kind of cool that they put
him in there because he was in all those
love CRA voice told man that's Jeffree
com he's like that's Jeffrey combes and
I was like it does kind of sound like
him doesn't it so he like so he looked
it up it was he was only like in one
scene yeah but was that the was it
Batman versus Dr no it was the Lovecraft
one like yeah Lovecraft was it yeah
doomed it something rather Doom that
came to Gotham yeah so yeah Jeffrey coms
did have like a one scene in that which
I thought was really funny he was also
in and I only remembered this movie
because I think I reviewed it like on my
flickers of fear series but I was just
thinking about it the other day because
I think um Brandon tennel did a video
about it and it was called abominable
and it was like about a killer Sasquatch
and um Jeffrey comes was in that too
like playing this
[__] like Backwoods rednet kind of
character and he was like [__]
hilarious that's a great movie by the
way like a great yeah uh monster movie I
can't remember what year it came out
it's not that old but I think Lance
henriksson was in it too like a lot of
kind of big like stars were in it but
that that see that's the thing I like I
said I I get it if you're an actor you
don't want to be typ cast in a certain
type of genre or something like that
especially something like horror which
while it's not as disparaged as it used
to be is still not like a super Prestige
genre I get that but it's better than
not working it's yeah one it's better
than not working and two and I've said
this before I will submit that horror
fans are the most loyal and will [__]
you're in a good horror movie those fans
will stick with you for [__] ever you
just run the convention scenes yeah you
go to conventions and everybody will
turn up and pay for your [__]
autograph for years and years and years
until you're a very old person yeah
because they just love that [__] yeah
they'll come to the table down there and
they'll spend 50 bucks to talk to you at
the table for 10 minutes yeah yep I mean
they're I think they're doing uh is
Spooky Empire going on this weekend
probably or it went on last weekend I
can't remember y uh John gor said Mark
Hamill plays a stone cold psycho along
the lines of Peter Lori in sushi girl
I've actually never seen that uh had
Tony Todd in it too it was okay okay oh
that kind of sounds like something I
might need to see I love Tony Todd he
why isn't he in more stuff if I was H I
would have gone the same way
that
um
man the same way that he what's [__]
dude we were just talking about Jeffrey
comes Jeffrey comes I would have done
the same thing that's what I would have
done he because he could have done it
and he would have had a bunch of horror
fans yeah I'd have been in horror movies
and Sci-Fi movies and um I mean he was
in the mcgyver one of the worst science
fiction movies of all time we're going
to have to review that at some point cuz
I kind of want to rewatch it I remember
it was pretty terrible but I haven't
seen it in a long time I was in the Army
I rented
that on VHS cuz I think it was on it's
on two or something cuz I was just
scrolling through the other day and I
was like oh we should totally watch that
when I was at Fort Cabell you know
[__] would if it was like a bad
weekend or didn't have that buy to go
out [__] I'd uh get some booze and go
hop on the ninja had a ninja 600 at the
time going out and rent uh I get some
booze I would [__] get a damn pizza
I'd have that delivered to the have some
Domino's pizza delivered or was it Papa
John yeah Papa John's have that
delivered to my
Barracks my barracks room we had a
little Twan apartments and uh I'd watch
anime flicks yeah yeah like apple seed
and the Kira oh yeah well I started
running out of started running out of
anime and one of so I got I got the guy
possible yeah yeah drunk watching the
gerver eating pizza that sounds like a
that sounds like a fun fight yeah in the
Army on a
Saturday [__] cob running around
yelling outside [__] my little drunk
friend the one that threw in that girl's
head R what you doing in there man
watching them Japanese cartoons come on
out of here man yeah he's like that
watching them nerd watching those
Japanese cartoons man nerd come on out
here well they everybody liked them yeah
I know yeah we all watch that kind of
[__] it's like even back then I think
the perception was that like only nerds
watch that but a lot of people watch
depend what generation you were
Generation X we like that [__] yeah
they're watching Akira and [__] yeah
depend on what it
was cuz you know uh that's considered to
be like new kind of new and exotic yeah
anime that was you know
93 you know we had D listen to goth
music and [__] yeah and I was in the
Recon tune man [__] D was amazed that
I had a specimens album nice I had
specimens and I had uh uh [__]
Sisters of Mercy and stuff and a Peter
Murphy album and beler was like dude you
know this stuff he go yeah go you like
golf music he said yeah
yeah you know we it was hard to like
find people that liked the people didn't
know they didn't have the internet we
didn't have the internet so but the
squad leader I had for a while sarden
Smith man he was a huge uh he was a huge
Smith's fan yeah yeah he used and we we
got deployed to Egypt he drove he would
drive the patrol vehicle there'd be four
of us in the vehicle I'd be in the back
a lot of times well we we rotated
positions but you could be in the back
as a machine
gunner and he'd roll the windows down
and [__] be blasting the Cure we're
out in the middle of the [__] Sinai
desert it's like being on the surface of
Mars you didn't have to be tactical
nothing was camouflaged you were just
doing a patrol route to get to these
certain locations at certain times and
there's awax planes flying
over it was just kind of a kind of a
[__] job
really [__] around with the ban the
beta uh trading with them smoking opium
smoke no I didn't smoke opium smoke uh
shisha yeah yeah drinking Kade day it's
like this uh they called it desert Apple
tea but I don't know what it was it was
probably something tasted more like
something along lines of
cranberry cranberry or pomegranate tea
what it was like it was
red and uh but no we'd be out there
[__] blasting disintegration album or
the Kissy Kissy Kissy
album in the middle of the desert middle
of the [__] desert yeah that's pretty
cool I can kind of picture it yeah I'm
picturing that soundtrack yeah soon as
it started getting dark we had to start
heading in man the temperatur start
falling so you know how like you know
how like in
[__] you know how like in
uh [__] Empire Strikes Back they had
to close the blast doors because it's
going to get too cold at night that's
what that's what it was like out in the
desert we got to get the [__] in man the
sun's going down it's going to get cold
as [__] because it got real cold certain
they eventually yeah yeah it'd be hot in
the day real cold at night grur said uh
Mark Hill didn't have much range yeah I
will agree with that uh and also Allison
reminds me uh that Mark Hill was in body
bags the John Carpenter Anthology film
which I feel like more people need to
see that I feel like it's really
underrated I think it came out in 1993
it's good yeah and Mark Hill is actually
really good in that I forgot I forgot
that he was in there yeah he was in like
the I think it was the last segment that
is super we reviewed it like a long time
ago but um that is a super super fun
Anthology film and I feel like a lot of
people forget about it even people that
are like talking about John Carpenter
stuff like kind of forget to mention it
but it's really good it's one of his
better ones um yeah and then grur said
uh H he was in a World War II movie
called The Big Red One oh yeah I
remember I remember that too yeah been a
long time I forgot about that and then
Zach says same issue with a lot of
Marvel actors they start in the big tent
pole movies to get paid and then do
Little Indie dramas to actually act but
no one ever sees those yeah I mean
that's the thing you get like a big
[__] millions and millions of dollar
payout for doing that and then you can
just do stuff that you want to do which
I guess is kind of nice if I remember
correctly Big Red One had Lee Marvin in
it I think it's one of his late later
movies you guys can correct me yeah was
it it's been a long time since I've seen
I that might have had Lee Marvin in it
it was a World War II movie from the 80s
yeah was it I thought it was later than
that no ' 80s now I can't remember 80s
and then Oracle said the voice acting
has been Hamill's salvation in my
opinion because he's got a decent range
of voices and can deliver different
characters yeah um and that seems to be
like the direction that he went in he
became kind of beloved for doing that so
I guess it's good that he kind of found
that Niche he was really funny he turned
up on one of the newer Mystery Science
Theater episodes too like in a really
funny sketch he's a big fan of that show
too kind of reminded me of what I was
talking about I was watching Guyver the
guy for had Mark Hamill in
it and it was one of those kind of
movies where
I really liked the idea of it it had
some good
ideas and parts of the the costumes were
really cool all right it looked
good but man that was it it was
like dialogue was [__] up and they had
some stupid homages like they had the
the dude who
was played JJ from Good Times what was
that guy's name oh Jimmy Walker Jimmy
Walker's in it yeah all right he turns
into his monster form and [__] it is the
[__] most ridiculous looking monster
I've ever seen I think I vaguely
remember that yeah it it looks like you
go to Disneyland you know they make
those [__] distorted drawings of your
face they're like that comedic as [__]
and they're having rap battles in the M
that's so [__] 90s oh my God we got
to watch this now totally I had totally
forgotten about yeah the monsters were
having rap battles in the [__] in the
movie that makes total sense yeah it
made no [__] sense it's just that the
Japanese were trying to be very American
I I guess the Japanese were involved in
that yeah it was originally a Japanese
now I did remember I did see the
anime of the guy it was a lot better the
anime was the Japanese anime was a lot
better of course although it still had a
lot of the same problems that anime has
which is like schizophrenic storytelling
and you know there's not a whole lot of
damn continuity and uh over-the toop
emotions and weird voice acting but but
that was kind of the ex that was kind of
the what you were what I was in a way
looking for when I was watching those at
in my 20s when they were kind of they
were kind of newish you know they were
new to America it was just an alien
experience yeah you know like well yeah
it's something different I think that's
what appealed to people
yeah although some of them weren't Akira
was almost kind of like a western movie
it had some japaneseness to it kind of
like Blade
Runner but it was it was more coherent
some of that [__] was just totally
incoherent yeah I've seen some an I was
just like I'd be lying if [__] if I knew
what the [__] was going on
yeah then some of them were pretty like
uh fun to watch like uh Tank Police
Dominion Tank Police I think I saw two
or three of those and it was just cute
anime girls who were cops that were
equipped with tanks [__] then they
have to fight other tanks that was a
trip apple seed was pretty good from
what I remember but I don't remember
much about it I just remember liking
it yeah I think a lot of people like
that one that's one I hear brought up a
lot
yeah been a long time since I've seen
this old classic anime weird weird [__]
Zach says I may have asked before but I
don't remember what's the most beautiful
looking movie you guys have seen the
most beautiful looking movie how do you
define beautiful well I guess it's
subjective so it's entirely up to you
I'm going to say Blade Runner that's a
good answer Blade Runner has a [__]
fantastic look to it it always did and
it holds up it and it still looks
[__] great and and 2049 looks
fantastic also that was like and that
was really good to see in the on the big
screen because although I must say that
I liked 2049 a lot but the first one the
props had a very handcrafted look to
them because they were you know what I
mean and the second
one the props that they're handling do
look like something that came out of a
corporation which yeah yeah give you
that they looked more realistic right
yeah like something that corporations
made but I guess that's what they wanted
I but there's just something about the
old Blade Runner everything that they
show you was was odd for those days you
could probably see it now a kid would
probably see it now and probably
wouldn't notice how strange that was but
it was real strange to see the [__] that
they were showing you like the guns and
the even the clothes they were kind of
off everything was custom made and it
was wasn't something you'd actually see
the 80s yeah it was something that you
could only kind of
imagine and um just the city
Scapes you know the the Billboards and
the although the second one I have it
it's got a lot of good little
details that was pretty gorgeous there
gorgeous Holograms and the new ones
there the city's filled with
advertisement
Holograms what's the name of that cute
Latina girl that was in bond and was in
that movie Anor de armas Anor de
armas I went back to go look at some of
those
Graphics like when he goes into the the
little open air bar and the replicate
hookers make a move on him before he
gets there you see a a hologram of a
girl dancing with something in her hand
went back to see what that was and then
I Googled to see what that was and what
it was
saying it's it's a it's a fake saki
commercial
and it's diis who's doing the dancing
it's her oh okay it's her in the in the
Hologram okay because that was Joy yeah
and joy was copyrighted yeah so that her
the company that owned that image used
her in a [__] ton of advertising right
and it's it's advertisement for a saki
commercial that's what it was yeah
because didn't he he would like pass by
and they had and she was in like
Billboards of her and stuff like that
because that was like her their creation
yeah and according to like who the guys
that were talking
about talking about the movie and cuz
there's like leaks and and you know what
I mean and [__] from from the
production of the movie The Concept was
is that Joy was algorithmically selected
by men's presence to to be M the perfect
woman yeah out of like what the average
guy
wanted so so they used her for
advertising
too because she f she fell into right
into into the concept of perfection at
the time right so she was like an asset
because but she's an AI supermodel yeah
but she was owned Yeah by those
companies which that that but when you
come to think it sounds ridiculous but
then you go no that's what they would do
yeah of course that's exactly what they
do that's not weird at all no because
they would do that they do that without
they do that without you thinking about
like Sonic the Hedgehog you immediately
recognize Sonic the Hedgehog that's an
artificial image that that guy doesn't
exist that little
hedgehog if you saw an ad with Hedgehog
in it they would use the they use ads
with the Mario brothers the Super Mario
in it they got a whole well that's what
they're doing yeah same kind of thing
same thing yeah so okay so Zach's
answers are uh lately the one he just
saw the new Martin scori movie Killers
with the flower Moon uh either that
Skyfall hereditary that's a good one uh
Carrie or Clute we still have to review
that I'm sorry we haven't done it I'm
pretty sure it's on HBO Max we will
watch cuz I've been wanting to rewatch
it so I know I've keep saying that um
John goris said Days of Heaven the
Terren Malik film A Thin Red Line that's
a good one wings of Desire o that's a
real good one uh Picnic at Hanging Rock
yeah that's actually one of my favorite
movies that movie is so [__] creepy
and it looks really good but um I'm
going to say older movies um susperia
the original susperia from 1977 I love
love every frame looked of that movie
yeah like the new one they went he went
the complete opposite direction with it
where he made it like all dank and you
know gray and communist and and I
thought that was probably a good idea
just so you wouldn't like compare it
because the the 1977 one is so
Fantastical and like a fairy tale and
it's like these super saturated colors
and uh and all that kind of stuff so but
yeah they're both beautiful in different
ways I guess as far as more recent
movies probably Fury Road yeah um cuz I
just I thought like the visuals in that
were just [__] breathtaking Jenny
said that the a furiosa movie made it's
done it's ready that's what I heard I
heard that it was in post production and
it's got that diis chick that I just
mentioned she's in it cuz I think it's a
prequel it's a prequel yeah it gives you
the story of of uh of furiosa yeah like
her origin story that's what I heard I
don't know if that's the case but some
dudes going to be crying about oh man
it's going to be a chick flick or
whatever they didn't even like they
didn't even like Fury Road they thought
the [__] was like some kind of woke
thing I know what it was that they're
talking about but they're they're
misinterpreting that movie that is dumb
as [__] say dumb [__] like that they got
dudes that can't grasp Artistry and they
don't understand and they don't
understand um kind of like Alchemy in a
certain way that movie when you look at
it was centered around
fluids okay it was milk and blood all
right and
Fuel and water yeah all right and then
male and female all right which they're
talking this is an Alchemy thing but not
Mo not ancient Alchemy a futuristic
post-apocalyptic alchemical symbolism
going on in the
story and um just because characters say
certain things like the Fe the female
character said you guys deserve this
because you guys destroyed the world
that's what just because she said that
that doesn't mean the that's the meaning
of the
movie that is what their tutor said what
was her name um the woman that had all
the tattoos all over what was her name
uh I can't remember [__] he called
her she had told them a bunch of stuff
that caused them to leave and to Rebel
it's a long story it's just talking
about different points of
view okay that that's all that's all it
is and it was uh it was kind of
symbolically a struggle between male
female and all of the fluids in the
movie but in the end it had all worked
out which Miss Kitty somebody said Miss
Kitty that's right Miss Kitty thank you
Miss giddy it was either giddy or Kitty
I don't remember I think he said Miss
giddy yeah I thought it was giddy with a
G but I could yeah I think so I don't
know and there's a lot of misconceptions
about imort and
Joe on the surface you could say and
Morton Joe was the bad guy but Morton
Joe was in a way the good guy it just a
lot of it had to do with the point of
view he was trying to bring back human
Civilization by having healthy
heirs so he had all those girls who
evident and they they were in there's
Comics that explain where they came
from they had all joined up to volunteer
to go into this breeding program
remember they were all trying to fight
to get into the
Citadel The Citadel was a damn Mountain
Fortress that had
water and there's I I read the prequel
comic books that explain how Morton Joe
and the guys that ran the bullet form
and all how they got a hold of all this
stuff it was during the apocalypse they
were exmilitary guys they were ex
Special Forces Australian Special Forces
guys and they fought to get all that
[__] and then once they got in there
they tried to bring back
civilization
um but they were so damaged from
radiation and [__] they were having
mutants as
children and the thinking Morton's Joe's
thinking was um that if you had healthy
heirs that you could bring back
Civilization
now his men were only in the Citadel
everybody else were just people of the
Wasteland that weren't his
citizens all this stuff about giving
them water he didn't have to give them
water he just did but he considered them
to be dying which they were they didn't
live very long so he thought it was
wasting resources on them he wanted to
bring back normal human
beings who weren't mutated so the girls
had kind of volunteered for
that now he was not having sex with him
he couldn't get it up and a lot of him
was cancerous so it was all artificial
insemination that that's what was
happening there in the comic books and
Morton Joe actually was into
boys all the war boys and everything
that's why he was call he they were
calling him daddy [__] like that see he
was kind of a leather daddy you know
it's it was an interesting story though
um and when he
would when uh in the comic book when
uh when those girls were around him for
the artificial insemination he'd have
them dressed up as War boys and they the
girls thought that was kind of strange
but he was that was his his Kink I guess
he wasn't into
girls but
um I'm I'm I'm looking forward to seeing
the
uh the F movie it's GNA be good I think
I think I mean furosa was a great
character as long as it's the same
director it'll be good yeah I mean they
spend a lot of money making Vehicles
yeah they may spend a lot of money
making Vehicles Miller said he has
underst studies that can do it when he's
dead yeah cuz he's getting older now but
I'm pretty sure like you know he was at
the helm of this one he said he's got
guys that he can trust that know the the
the the culture that he's thinking and
everything cuz man when I saw that movie
at first I'm like oh my God this needs
to be a whole they need to make a whole
movie about her part of it was the the M
the soundtrack The Music everything
about that movie and I've probably seen
that movie 10 times at this point we saw
it six times in the theater yeah the
first time we saw it cuz remember we
came out and I said I just I feel like I
just got my ass kicked
yeah the whole story was from a story
board when you can tell I mean it was
just it was so good like everything
about it it was just so propulsive it's
just like it was visually gorgeous it
was like the sound design was amazing
the acting was amazing it's just like
one of the best movies of like the last
several years you know yeah um so other
people are talking about other beautiful
movies uh Quon yeah o that's a good one
too Mark of the witch
1974 Oracle says I'm going to be weird
and say Fargo is one of the most
beautiful movies I've seen that's not
weird um that is like all those big like
snowy Minnesota Lance well yeah it's
supposed to be Minnesota but it's not
isn't it is it um Oscar says Hey Oscar's
here saw when evil lurks last week yeah
I've been hearing about that easily the
scariest movie since hereditary oo
that's um that's got me intrigued
because yeah hereditary [__] me up
yeah J John's saying that toe cutter and
humongous were kind of tops that they
didn't seem to be into women and yeah
Miller one of the explanations that I
read was is
that Miller
envisioned the collapse of civilization
to also be the collapse of any societal
norms and what would emerge would be
kind of like tribal hyper masculinity
and something similar to like um prison
Maximum Security Prison
cultures to where some guys would think
that women were too weak to survive and
not of Great Value you that only other
men would be of value which that's a
[__]
great angle for an apocalyptic movie you
know but yeah evidently
uh when you when you read the the comic
prequels [__] Joe was like that hyper
masculinity
basically John gor said uh the amondo de
asorio of tombs of the blind dead Fame I
just reviewed tombs of the blind dead
not too long ago uh fangs of the Living
Dead uh looks lovely like an old Aurora
model kit come to life I don't think
I've seen that that one or if I did it
was a long time ago um other beautiful
movies with psycho that's a good pick
Edward Scissor Hands uh Marne that the
Alfred Hitchcock movie which I haven't
seen in a very long time dreams the
Akira kurasawa film I agree that is a
gorgeous movie like all of these are
really good picks a lot better than mine
I think I'm glad that he put picked that
up about toe cutter though toe cutter
there's a there's a homosexual in the
first movie there's a homosexual
inference between toe cutter and [__]
Billy the
boy and he tells Bubba to go [__] go
back to get Billy the boy go I don't
want to do it for him it's not for him
it's for me you know what you're doing
you're doing for me bubba you know just
it's it's there's a lot of that going on
if you look at Bubba
zetti and I like the Bubba zetti
character um he probably should have
been the leader of that group of that
gang but toe cutter was in there
inherited it from the Night Rider but uh
if you look closely Bubba zanette is
wearing a [__] girl
shirt
I mean it it it it's it's a tank top I
wear [__] like that but his the cut of
his for the 80s that would have been a
girl shirt he had uh the short white
hair kind of
like kind of like uh [__] uh Rob
howford from Judas Priest and wear an
eyeliner and you know toe cutter wore
eyeliner on one eye and one eyebrow just
they were just they were and then
there's could that have been an homage
to Clockwork Orange though because Alex
wear the the lashes just on one eye and
in that one
scene the two gangsters [__] when
they're taking over the
town they uh those two guys [__] do a
two versus one on that one civilian guy
and the inferis is that they're going to
rape that guy now they don't they end up
throwing him through the window
but you go back and watch Mad Max one I
love Mad Max one nobody talks about it
that's [__] awesome movie great movie
uh but yeah there's a lot
of hints that the motorcycle gang were I
wouldn't say homosexual I would say they
were
[__] just Broadband just freakazoids
they just had sex with they wanted to
it's about more about power I think like
like something out of
prison Oscar also brings up Melancholia
as a gorgeous movie yeah I agree with
that um I like a lot of like black and
white films too like just the cinema
photography of him I'm really into like
I really like um the
Innocence um The Haunting from
1963 uh Seance on a wet
afternoon like movies like that um what
is the one uh hour of the wolf the Amar
Bergman film which is really weird if
you haven't never seen it that was like
the closest thing to a horror film that
he ever did it's very David Lynch you
can tell that David Lynch was really
into that movie although I think that
David Lynch was kind of I think he was
more into like Persona that other one
but um yeah like hour the wolf is like
is really [__] cool if you've never
seen
it Zach says uh not a movie but I love
the look of True Detective season one
yeah yeah yeah yeah and The Last of Us
yeah we never did finish that did we we
started watching it and then we didn't
finish it Isabella said um also the
thief of Baghdad from 1924 and she from
1935 I just watched she not too long ago
matter of fact uh Zach brings up
nocturnal animals yeah that's I still
haven't seen that I still got to get
around to seeing that an atonement I saw
that in the theater I read the book too
if you haven't read the book the book is
I mean the movie is great but the book
is much better it always is but I was
really into that book
actually and then Allison's talking
about verer Herzog all his movies with
clous kinsky that [__] scary
[__] we still need to
review my best fiend the documentary
about verer Herzog and cl kinsky Oscar
Petz is here what's up Oscar yeah I know
he's asking Who's That B I got the B
costume I got the ban costume I think I
have decid I guess I will go with the
Vampire Amy from Fright Night costume
because it's been three years since I
wore that and I didn't go out in it I
don't think so it's not like everybody
saw it you know what I mean I think I
posted one picture but that was a while
back so nobody remembers I'm
sure but you know I think it's probably
time do I need another drink I need
another drink good cuz you know it's
only 8:30 and I'm not going any place
where's other
so I'm trying to think I'm trying to
think of other movies that really struck
me with
their it's kind of hard to think of just
like on the fly like that like I said
most of the stuff that I can think of is
probably going to be like horror movies
because that's mostly what I watch I've
seen
like I don't know I've seen I don't want
to say I've seen pretty much everything
I've seen a lot I've seen a lot of
movies and I've seen like pretty much
like all the classics and all that kind
of stuff because I kind of made it a
mission to do that I haven't seen a lot
of newer stuff I don't watch a lot of um
you know genres that I'm not really into
so I don't see a lot of comedies or
anything like that like recent ones but
oh I
saw that new horror movie that a lot of
people are talking about cobweb they put
it up on Hulu and I watched that and
that was pretty good that was pretty
good um it was pretty creepy kind of
reminded me of well I think a lot of
people are saying it's kind of like the
bobok but it's
not I get it was kind of similar
thematically but really like the story
was not the same and I don't think it
was as creepy as the Boba duck but it
was still pretty creepy it was still
pretty creepy but it was like it was so
dark though I couldn't tell what was
going on most of the time to be honest
with you you know but it was pretty PR
good um and have you seen like I guess
thank you Bryce uh Tommy look jacked
what do you guys think of Richard Layman
I read his book Beast house and it's
disturbing I've done I haven't read a
[__] ton of his books um but I've read a
handful if you're interested I actually
did a video on his book what the [__] is
it called uh I think it's called come
out tonight and I did a video on it
Richard Layman
um was kind of like this is the guy I'm
thinking of right
where every single thing that he writes
he was very because like in the 80s and
90s there was like a big trend for so
like extreme horror you know what I mean
you had people like Edward Lee and um
you know Jack Ketchum and Richard Layman
and people like that where they was just
like they'd write these horror novels
that were like super gory and like super
pornographic and so there was and they
would put them out like Leisure books
put a lot of them out um you know as
paperbacks and I have a bunch of them
still like I have a bunch of them on my
shelves um you know Douglas kle that was
another guy that I read a lot of Richard
Layman his stuff was like is so funny to
me because it's just he wrote like and
he was just kind of like he's he's
passed away uh now but he wrote like an
overheated teenage boys fantasy you know
what I mean like the one that I reviewed
of his was about this woman who's at the
very beginning she's having sex with her
boyfriend or she wants to have sex with
her boyfriend they don't have condom so
he has to go to the convenience store to
get some or whatever and then he doesn't
come back and so she waits for a long
time and then like a dumbass she's like
oh I'm going to go walk down there in
the middle of the night like in this
super sketchy neighborhood and like see
what happened to him she ends up getting
picked up by this teenager who's also
like a student of hers CU she's like a
Subs teacher or something and he ends up
like raping her and torturing her and
thinking that he kills her and he dumps
her off this overpass but she's still
alive and then she falls into the
clutches of these other two teenage boys
who literally the first thought that
they have when they see what they think
is a dead woman like laying at the
bottom of the because he she falls like
into like near their yard or something
they're like should we turn her over and
look at her tits and I was just kind of
like accurate but it's a little yeah so
it's just kind of like it's a funny
funny book like it's it I don't know
some people might think it was
disturbing I just kind of thought it was
hilarious but um it's hilarious for like
a lot of reasons but his books are fun
they're just like
trashy and I read one that he I don't
remember if I did a review of it or not
I probably did I think it's called body
rides and it was about I can't even
remember what the [__] it was about now
but it was just like about this thing
was it a ring I can't I can't remember
but it would like let you go into
somebody else's body like without them
and you could like quote unquote ride
them around so you could like be
somebody else kind of like being John
malovich I guess but um if you've seen
that movie The Charlie Koffman one but
um so it's kind of like that but then
there was like that was like a really
weird I don't know it just went off in
like this really weird Direction there
was like this weird love story and it
was I don't know it was totally bizarre
it was really bizarre I think I did a
video review of it I don't know if I did
a written one but um yeah so I've read
some of his stuff it's he he's if you're
in the right mood for that um then it's
a lot they're a lot of fun if you're
just in the mood for like some sleazy
porny gory trash then they're pretty
good although I would argue that a lot
of the other kind of leisure books
authors as I kind of think of them um
from that time period were better
writers um but cuz his stuff is kind of
juvenile but sometimes you want that you
know sometimes you're kind of in the
mood for that I mean that book that I
did of his I just found it like in a
secondhand bookstore and I was like oh
my God Richard Layman I haven't read his
St for a long time so I picked it up and
read it I was just like oh my
God this is [__] ridiculous and it
was just like cracking me up it's like
and it cracked me up like doing the
review of it too because I'm just like
oh my God this is [__] crazy but you
know what I mean
um Joseph says a blurb described Richard
Layman as Stephen King Without a
conscience
that's pretty good actually that's
pretty good although I would argue like
I said Richard Layman stuff is a lot
more extreme than I don't know I guess
some of Stephen King's but I don't know
I don't know if I'd call some of Stephen
King stuff extreme but um Richard Layman
stuff is like way more extreme and like
mean-spirited you know what I mean yeah
just talking about the splatter Punk
movement yeah I got kind of I'm not
super into it like I'm not super
into quote unquote extreme horror but I
do read it on occasion like I've done
some uh reviews recently of some kind of
Infamous extreme horror like um womb by
Duncan Rolston which actually I quite
liked um and that Book
Cows which was pretty [__] up um I
don't know if I've ever read anything
that just made me like oh my God I can't
read this anymore although I have heard
there's a book
called if you know anything about
extreme horror like this one kind of
made the rounds I think it's called Dead
Inside what the [__] is the name of the
author I can't remember now but a lot
it's a necro it's necrophilia but
there's other [__] going on in there too
and apparently like a lot of people
reviewed this one and they were like
this is the most revolting thing that
I've ever [__] read and I was just
like now I'm kind of tempted you know
what I mean you've WR you've you've
written some pretty revolting [__] true
yeah I really only read one of her
stories though but she told me about
some of this stuff that's happened I
read one only read one of Jen's stories
because I [__] hate reading if she'
read it to me then after my head
injuries after my head injury I [__]
I have a hard time reading a long story
because my eyes will go down they'll go
across the lines and then three
sentences into it my eyes will jump up
back to the top of the paragraph again
yeah I have to read it
again like I have no problem
communicating online yeah but if it's a
long
stories and I never really could break
the Habit after my head injury of doing
that I said stop it no I wasn't there
and I have to go back to the line that I
was
at it's kind of like for about six
months after that motorcycle wreck I
walked I couldn't walk in a straight
line I walked in a slight Bend and I'd
have to hit the wall and then push my
way off of it it's like that you ever
seen a [__] remember that time we saw
that posum walking in a circle yeah
that's right the in the road yeah soon
as I saw that he got a head injury yeah
yeah we got him off the road anyway yeah
cop came and got
him I wrote a story once about a pair of
circus performers who were conjoined
twins like it was an old and they were
old guys now yeah and one guy had his
brother like growing out of his back or
something and their whole Act was like
the the brother would like eat [__] out
of the out of his Big Brother's [__]
and then like they got this wasting
disease that like turned them into this
like yeah like turned them into this
like shitty soup and then like so the
main one was like he just kept eating
the other brother and then like [__]
him back out and like eating him again
my goal was for that I had just read
this really revolting story I can't even
remember who wrote it now it was like in
an anthology and I said I want to write
something that just like makes me so
like I'm going to I want to write
something that makes me gag like while
I'm writing it so I wrote this story and
I was like well it worked cuz it's
pretty [__] great even when I reread
it now I'm just like God I can't believe
I [__] wrote that but yeah it's like
disgusting but I don't usually write
like scatalogical stuff like that but um
but yeah this I what the [__] was the
name of that I can't remember the name
of that I'll think of it in a minute the
process of elimination I think was the
name of the story uh Mike bar Mike
Barrett says uh just finished reading
the girl next door pretty messed up that
is
honestly that's Jack Ketchum by the way
um that's one of the most messed up
books and it's more messed up because
it's Loosely based on a real case uh
they've actually made two movie
adaptations of that there's one that was
called The Girl Next Door and one I
think is called An American Crime um and
they're both I mean the real story is
[__] up and the book which is
fictionalized but is pretty much based
on what kind of what happened he just
changed some of the details the that's
one of those books where you just like
feel like you need a shower afterward
like a silkwood shower because you know
what I'm saying because it's really
disturbing Jack Ketchum was really good
at that I think he was of all the kind
of quote unquote splatter Punk writers
that were around at that time I think he
was the best writer he was real into cuz
some of the other ones like you know
Richard Layman and Douglas kle and stuff
like that they were more into I want to
say like more Supernatural kind of stuff
like Clyde barkery type of like demons
and you know Gore dimensions and stuff
like that but Jack Ketchum was very
into the gravities that humans were
capable of that was where he found his
horror if you've never read he wrote a
book called red and I didn't read it for
a long time because I knew what it was
about um but I finally did read it
recently and it's um basically what
happens the reason why I didn't want to
read it was because I knew that at the
beginning and this isn't a spoiler
because this happens like in the first
few pages this there's this nice old man
and he has a dog named red and these
stupid like Teenage snot no
douchebags um like basically blow his
dog's head off like with a rifle just
for shits and giggles and then the rest
of the book is this old man trying to
get like justice for his dog and like
this it just it getting more and this
came out like way before John Wick so
it's not I mean this is an old book I
think it came out in the 90s I think or
maybe '
80s and um just the I don't even want to
say like the disintegration of the
morality of the old man cuz I because
everything that he does cuz he puts up
with a lot I'm going to say like before
he just goes full on like scorched Earth
and decides he's going to like just [__]
him up you know what I mean and you
can't really blame him because what the
[__] but it was yeah but it's a
disturbing book everything that Jack
Ketchum writes is really disturbing
because like I said there's no
Supernatural [__] it's always like just
horrible horrible people doing horrible
things or just like completely losing
their moral compass and things like that
it's just he was really really good at
and I said Jack Ketchum isn't even his
real name I didn't even realize that
it's a pen name I can't remember what
his real name is but uh back in here
saying
hi come here come up on the show come up
on the show what do you mean no tell me
no she's like but I tell me no she's
like that tell me no she's like oh okay
I'll look everybody see look in the
camera see no tail yeah don't touch the
tail she's like don't touch my
stump her little her little
popsicle she looks like a little a
little what are those things like a
little otter poop that's what we call
her sometimes yeah um John gor said I
only just saw Martyrs the other day
that's a hell of a movie it is um again
it's that's another one that and I did a
review of this one a while back and I
think I said in the review it's like I
don't blame you if you don't want to
watch it because there's some ideas and
some images in there that probably you
don't want in your brain but I mean I
thought it was phenomenal but it's hard
to watch though it is really hard to
watch and I have to
be I have to be in the right mood for
that kind of thing it's interesting
because I was watching there's this
woman that I subscrib to like she's like
a horror fan I think what's her name of
her Channel I think it's spooky asut she
has like a lot of
followers and periodically she will do
videos she's much more she's much
younger than I am so she's a much more
she likes some of the older movies but
she's much more she likes stuff from
like the '90s 2000s and everything which
okay I can't really hang with that but
all right um depends on what it is
that's what I mean I I like I like
horror movies from all eras like I'm not
snotty like that but I I I kind of like
resonate more with people that don't
have a partic that just will watch
anything from any era cuz I I really
don't like people that are like oh
that's old I don't want to watch that
they don't know what they're missing
like they yeah that's what I mean or or
they don't get it you know man I like
some [__] from the 30s man I the [__]
sh I love I love silent movies I I
really like silent movies like there's
just a whole the whole vibe about like
we said depends on what it is yeah like
not everything from every era is good no
most of the [__] from the 30s 30s to 50s
and the 20s sucked most of it but some
of the horror movies were [__] great
but they're within a little
Spectrum you know what I mean their
bandwidth is kind of narrow there's [__]
that they couldn't do but they are still
good movies yeah if you don't believe me
if you never watched the old
movie I want you to watch the black cat
with Boris caroff and
bellosi that movie is deep when you
think about
it
Satanism
necrophilia implied torture yeah someone
gets skinned alive so stealing people's
[__] mother wife [__] teams and
[__] [__] you steal a dude's wife and
the daughter
uh uh send and D to prison for
nothing human
sacrifice and it's a lot of it's just
implied you have to slow down and pay
attention to the
story because there were stuff that they
couldn't say and they're showing you
beautiful women in
caskets and he didn't say he's having
sex with them he says he's just keeping
them for their beauty I mean that's the
implication but you know that's not
what's going on yeah well they had to so
much
finessing because you could you couldn't
say certain things yeah yeah what was
his name
Shar shaar perig perig was his name
right charal perig
charmal P it was something like that
charmal P Perl Pearl Zig that's what it
was that was the name of Boris Carlo's
character who he was a satanic
ex-military officer who had sacrificed
his unit
in a World War I Battle Zone No wasn't
World War one yeah was World War One
Battle Zone yeah he made sure his unit
lost on a certain location to to Des to
to to not to desecrate but
to to to consecrate the ground he was
going to put his [__] Castle
on that's some wild [__] man Boris Carlo
looked hot as [__] in this movie yeah
but yeah they were not quite as hot as
he did in the mummy like you know what I
mean carof yeah carof and losoi were in
their Prime then and I mean the mummy I
think Boris carof looked hot in both
configurations like both as the mummy
and as arith Bay yeah that's another
thing I had never seen yummy I'd never
seen the movie I'd never seen the mummy
movie The
Original I just saw the first time maybe
a couple months ago Jen showed it to
me it's Carlo's answer to loso's Dracula
yeah it's basically the same plot yeah
yeah very similar Carlo's going I can do
something like that that's not a not a
not a vampire and we'll have I I'll have
more dialogue and you'll know more about
me and it was well because it was
original it was an original story it
wasn't based off an existing yeah novel
or anything like Frankenstein or Dracula
had been I I thought it was going to be
kind of like a slasher with a mummy
running around killing people like
Frankenstein it's not what it's about
the sequels were like that yes that's
not with the original but Boris carof
wasn't in the sequels he's only a mummy
like that in the opening sequences when
you first see him yeah he's mostly just
like a dude then he then uh once he's
revived he becomes kind of like a like a
Dracula type figure he's an ancient
Egyptian sorcerer yes trying to bring
his wife back to life yeah and [__]
it's awesome he's living in a damn
[__] pad that's all ancient Egyptian
and [__] and he's cool as [__] real
slick
character and uh it matched you know
what I mean like uh I didn't know this
but carof was half Indian from his dad
was from India yep when you look at him
you would you would think he was just
like a white guy but back in those days
he got ethnic roles yeah a modern person
today doesn't see him as ethnic but
that's what he was because he just looks
like a white another white dude but he
got ethnic roles and that was one of the
things that he they were more attuned to
that kind of [__] yeah I guess they were
real sensitive about what your facial
features look like he's just like a cool
white dude to me now everybody's just
like whatever yeah like it does matter
yeah which is [__] Mexicans are white
now like I said I look at everybody to
me they're just white I like that it
doesn't really matter it don't matter
anymore like back then they were like
super picky yeah well because well there
were a lot of actors back then that were
quote unquote ethnic you know like Rita
Hayworth for example that was one that I
thought of um and they would try to like
wh ify them them and they probably
didn't even look that quote unquote
ethnic to start with but it's just like
like I said the the standards back then
were like you had it was very narrow you
have to be in this narrowness of like
white person yeah and if you fall
outside if your nose is a little bit too
wide or your skin is a little bit too
brown or something like that they got to
do [__] about that you had to be very
dramatic looking or Celtic looking
that's what that's kind of what yeah
like I said it was very narrow bandwidth
of like what you're were supposed to
look like Scandinavian Germanic are
Celtic which you know most
anglo-americans generically are like
that look like that even though you up
to Michigan and it's actually Slavs the
white people there are Slavic a lot of
them and then mixtures of Slavic and
Scandinavian it's just you know to be
honest with you all this kind of silly
[__] really I couldn't [__] tell you
like what [__] I looked like you know
you yeah it's just like a Celtic and
slightly American Indian probably
myth that it's hard to it's hard to say
you look at your family they just look
like Irish people yeah to me well that's
kind of where they're from like
everybody in the South's basically Irish
and Germanic pretty much yeah if you're
white if you're white if you're African
African American even you will be partly
Irish like uh mostly
mostly Mississippi I'm from Mississippi
originally it's the blackest State
really it's like 33%
black even
there most of them had Irish blood um a
good example would be
um um James old Jones he's from
Mississippi his family's from
Mississippi and he's afro
Irish and an American uh Soldier he was
a Army Ranger did the voice of Darth
Vader of course Darth Vader is an Army
Ranger from Mississippi of course that's
just how that shit's going to go all
right hilarious to think of Darth Vader
being from Mississippi yeah Mississippi
yeah and [__] thulsa
Doom snad yeah he's basically a mixed
race Irish
African Mississippian you
know
oh the riddle of Steel you know that
don't you boy let me tell you that great
role man [__]
even even when he was playing king of
Zamunda where he willed himself to death
in the [__] Coming to America too
that's [__] awesome yeah James Earl
Jones Legend Zach says I think my
favorite horror book I read that you
reviewed is the one about the girl who
moved into the old haunted house in
England those [__] Brothers
trafficked girls from can't remember the
name that was um no one gets out alive
by Adam Neville they actually that was a
great [__] book if you haven't read
that um Adam Neville also wrote the book
the ritual which they made a really good
movie of in I think 2017 which you
haven't seen that as really good they
made a movie if no one gets out alive
which I kind of liked but they changed a
lot they moved the setting to the United
States instead of England so they kind
of changed the cultural context a lot um
which I didn't really mind it uh it
wasn't as scary as the book um the
villains weren't as villainous
uh a lot of the sex slavery and like hey
I'm going to throw acid in your face
kind of they kind of like pulled back on
that which I thought was a mistake
because I thought it made it less scary
but I thought it was a pretty decent
movie but it's not read the book though
oh and also the movie leaves out the
whole final third of the book so if
you've seen the movie which I don't know
if a lot of people saw the movie but the
book has a whole other Koda that happens
at the end like that jumps ahead a
couple years or whatever Mike Barrett
brings up a good thing thing the black
cat was pre-code it was but that was one
of the movies that caused the code to
really come into effect because that was
the direction it was going and man I
wish it would have gone in that
direction because they were going to
come up with some wild ass
[__] but the difference between black
cat and a code movie wasn't that much
not really I mean not by today's
standards probably back then it seemed
like a bigger deal but by the day
standards you could have done the black
cat
code yeah explain to what I'm talking
about they're not American or they don't
know what we're talking about the haze
code came out well it's basically like a
censorship code it was like a list of
stuff that you couldn't put in movies
you know one of the big things was that
well obviously anything that was at all
questionable like as far as violence or
sex or anything like that you couldn't
put that in your movie and the bad guy
always had to get punished at the end
and I think that kind of went up until
probably the
50s maybe the I mean even Ed even Ed
Wood would put American government
propaganda in his movie without even
being paid by the American government he
was a patriotic guy he well and also he
was trying to get away with yeah and he
wanted to make sure they wouldn't come
after I think doing crazy [__] I think
that was the main uh motivator he wanted
everybody to know that he was a real
American and that this is not an
American not an anti-American mov he's
like well I'm going to put I'm going to
make a movie about crossdressing yeah
but I'm American but I but I'm going to
like put a whole thing like this as
educational so I can get away with that
he knew what he was doing even though
I'm going go ahead and give a star to
Edwood Edwood was American as a
[__] when he was a hero he was
very brave fought in the Battle of pelo
on the [__] island of pelo with some
of the most Savage fighting in all of
World War II out in the Pacific Islands
on P [__] insane [__] they were
headers and he went through that battle
according to him underneath his uniform
wearing women's underwear man good for
him I hope that's true I don't know I
don't know if it's true but I hope it is
he was he wasn't he didn't care about
getting killed he said he was afraid of
getting wounded because he wouldn't be
able to explain it to the Medics but he
had this thing where he was under
pressure and psychological pressure was
on him and if he had some women's
underwear on he'd felt more relaxed
which help him go kill Japanese I guess
but hey fair enough some people got
lucky rabbit's feet some people got R
panties but you know me
it's all good me murder hornet in the
com comments there we're we're we're VA
guys you know we we we're both [__] up
we got
[__] you know we got PTSD and [__]
but no I understand [__] you
know edw the [__] see the movie Edwood
if you want to know uh the Tim Burton
one yeah hly I think that other than
yeah he was a good guy other than
Beetlejuice I think that might be Tim
Burton's best movie
he uh Johnny Depp knocks it out of the
park that movie is so [__] good
Martin was [__] amazing in that [__]
edw was just a hack director out in La
[__] and trying to make a movie for
nothing out of nothing for nothing and
really kind of made
nothing uh he didn't really end up too
good he just ended up making porn and
then like he drank himself to death I
think which is kind of sad but I like
that the movie like didn't really
lionize him but it just kind of like it
captured his optimism and his Spirit
yeah and I like movies like that where
they're just kind of like it was kind of
like it reminded me of the movie that
they made that uh Eddie Murphy made
recently about Rudy Ray Moore yeah Rudy
Ray where it was just kind of like it's
all these kind of like Misfits getting
together to like make we're going to
make a movie CU that's what they want to
deal like more than anything in the
world and they don't have any money and
they don't have any Talent or anything
like that but it's still kind of like
inspiring and heartwarming I own that
movie yeah I kind of like that I own
that movie I got to go watch that again
that was uh for me Murphy's uh comeback
two or to fource that was a great
[__] movie that Rudy Ray Moore movie
what was the name of that Rudy Ray Moore
movie U great movie if you guys haven't
seen it seen it yeah what it just went
right a lot like Ed Wood yeah it's a
similar theme like I said it's just kind
of like that's that's why it reminded me
of that yeah because well that's why I
liked Edwood because it would be very
easy to like make fun of him obviously
because a lot of people have but I like
that Tim Burton like had so much
affection for him his vision yeah good
that he made this kind of like really
nice heartwarming movie about him Ed Ed
had he wanted to be a film maker in
Hollywood and he just didn't really have
the talent but he did have the willpower
and he was a combat
veteran uh he was had a crossdressing
fetish when he was under a lot of
pressure he want to put on an angora
sweater and dress in with we've all got
our things you know know what I mean
we've all got everything he had to keep
it secret from his girlfriends he was he
was straight but he wanted to wear
women's clothes and he had PTSD a lot of
the [__] that I've heard about him they
go yeah that's it it's
PTSD and if anybody has a right to
[__] call him PTSD it' be [__]
wood [__] he was on P loo that's
[__] hell on Earth man [__] so he
he saw some [__] yeah you know and that
generation was tougher they came from
rural backgrounds [__] hard work
[__] share crop and a lot of them
poverty but still combat's combat and
that was some of the worst combat ever
on those
islands they were just there to
exterminate the Japanese because you
couldn't take them prisoner what are you
going to do put bring them on the boat
with you you can't bring them on the
boat with
you and a lot of his [__] was just kind
of useless they could have went around
him and they would have starved to death
because the Japanese Navy wasn't
supplying them but the thinking of the
day was is that you fought the enemy no
matter where they
were that was kind of like the manly
thing to do so dudes kind of got killed
for nothing you could have just left the
Japanese there on those ISS they would
have
starved but
well they were like no we're not going
to do that we're going to fight him the
manly way you know
but okay that was the standard of the
day good way to get your ass killed but
okay a lot of them got killed they did
yeah but I would say that it wasn't for
nothing because uh wood lived an
interesting life he's remember
yeah you know that's we're still talking
about him now yeah that's not a like
[__] it was all for nothing no he no he
he did good and in a way I kind of wish
he had lived
to see how he got like
reassessed I grew up watching those
movies in [__] California be you know
before we [__]
moved on [__] Channel 13
KTV the [__] monster mat all right
Saturday mat Edwood movies I didn't know
who Bedwood was yeah but I remember
those
scenes you know and in a way I kind of
thought that's the way movies were
supposed to be you're little kid
watching them they have
voiceovers well and to be honest like
I've seen a lot of movies from the 1950s
and a lot of bad different and a lot of
bad movies from the 1950s and his
weren't really that much worse than some
of the other kind of like mediocre ones
from the ' 50s they're really about kind
of the same I mean you know they they
are a little bit worse like they're
noticeably worse but not that much worse
knocking the gravestones
throwing
bullets well they do that in a lot of
movies I've seen a lot of movies to
be the bullets dudes with [__]
pistols dressed as cops [__] talking
with the pistol and gesturing with the
pistols and pointing at people with the
pistols [__] that was edw movie well
like I said when they did those on MST
they had a [__] field day with that
with them like pointing the guns in
everybody's faces while they were
talking no I was talking about you know
I could shoot you right in the face
right now no we need to go fight these
monsters so funny never can't tell
what's going to happen so strange lights
in the
sky the cops were doing comedic routines
like [__] Laurel and Hardy yeah I
don't get it but you know they are a lot
of fun though I will admit plan nine
yeah I mean that's a hilarious [__]
movie it's hilar
bunny yeah you're stupid stupid
stupid
that was so great I mean that just whole
character was so great Jung said Noir
and horror are very related visually and
Outlook wise yeah that's true um I'm
kind of a little bit behind uh and then
Allison is agreeing with that being life
is grim yeah is the theme uh John goris
also said when we were talking about
Boris carof being half Indian uh he said
they barely let Italians on film before
the 70s yeah isn't it weird to think
about that like Italians were like
ethnic cuz now nobody thinks of Italians
as anything but white people but yeah
American as [__] and then Oracle says
Christopher Lee's Italian jeans because
yeah he was part of Italian too me he
was cast as villains for years yeah
that's true too yeah we talked about
that on our show that we did about
Christopher Lee and Peter Cushing it's
funny because [__] Christopher Lee
looks cool as [__] in every movie I've
seen him I watch anything with
Christopher old man [__] Star Wars 3
yeah two and three is Count Dooku I
think he did a great job I can't believe
that dude's as old as he was and he's
pulling that [__] off as a Sith Lord
yeah yeah he had some [__] gravito
man yeah Allison ask who's the dude on
your necklace this is HP Lovecraft yeah
that's who that is see the little
tentacles there's little tentacles like
around the side that's what that is
somebody gave me this my friend gave me
this for my birthday a long long time
ago she got it from like an Etsy store
but yeah it's HP
Lovecraft um let's see where was Victor
said that Italians are basically
European
Mexicans kind of
kind of I get it I get
it well the Spanish are kind of like
European Mexicans too I suppose all the
Mediterranean and all the Mediterranean
and Latins kind of you know because they
they had colonies that stretched
throughout the Central and South America
Indian blood and African blood went back
to
Spain Portugal and Italy but there was
also North African stuff going on but
they kind of look the same anyway it it
it's it's just genetic flow it's been
going on for [__] millions of
years people going to [__] it don't
matter what color they are you [__] the
people that live next to you yeah you
marry people that live next to you it's
just so it's just flowing it doesn't
matter where it is you know it doesn't
matter who you are where race is
temporary oh it always was new ones are
created
constantly yeah that's why I don't think
it really matters all that much not over
centuries and thousands of years yeah
like if you take long over time it
doesn't really
matter and uh Allison is talking about
William Castle William Castle produced
Rosemary's Baby yeah he did yeah William
Castle I mean he knew what he was
[__] doing man he did House on
Haunted Hill he did The Tingler he was
like the king of the [__] gimmicks he
was the dude that House on Haunted Hill
they had that thing what was it called
emero where you'd go in the theater and
like the skeleton would come out on the
like I think it was a glow-in-the-dark
skeleton and it would come out on the
wire like in the part of the movie where
the skeleton comes out and like pushes
that [__] into the Acid Bath or
whatever and then also um in The Tingler
with Vincent Price which I think we
reviewed not too long ago they would rig
the theater seats with buzzers like
vibrators so that it's like when they
said oh the tingers loosen this theater
and then they turn all the lights out
and then they would turn on some of the
seats so like people start screaming and
stuff yeah so
saying no the Spanish are wider than the
Italians okay well depends parts of
Spain up in Northern
Spain is Castile or castios and when you
and they were basically Germans and
Saxons going back a long time so they're
all related anyway they're they're all
interrelated I
mean what was
it one of the best British Queens was
actually Spanish
what was her name wasn't Isabella no it
was
uh but then if you actually look
through the genealogies a lot of the a
lot of the a lot of the Spanish ar
aristocracy were Saxons they were
Germans and the Saxons were kind of in
an Empire went all the way from the
British islands all the way out into
Russia they were like a trade Empire
they were even down in vakia where uh
Count Dracula was or Vlad Vlad sepes
Vlad the
Impaler they had Saxons there they had
Saxon Merchants they were called and
they called them
boars but the boars were
Saxons so all these people spread out
everywhere throughout all of Europe back
in The Honky motherland and they all
intermarried over time and there isn't
any Rhyme or Reason to it now you know
they're they're all cousins it doesn't
really matter
uh oracle's talking about uh bass Reeves
and that there's a movie coming out
about that uh for those who don't know
bass Reeves was a black US Marshall
captured over 3,000 men had a Native
American partner sidekick yeah was one
of The Inspirations for The Lone Ranger
yeah that new series that's coming out
now he would be yeah he would be a good
topic for a true crime episode yeah that
actually yeah we talked about him before
I mentioned him before yeah there's a
lot of stereotypes about what the Old
West what was I think there's a series
or a movie coming out there was there
was a lot of blacks a lot of a a lot of
blacks were involved in in um in the old
west and they weren't in these kind of
roles that a lot of Hollywood would show
you no they have [__] badasses you
you had to get it like you lived in the
old west you had black bounty hunters
bass was basic I would call Bass more
like a bounty
hunter um you had Buffalo soldiers who
were black Cavalry they were kind of
Cavalry they did [__] good but here's
another thing is they had Indian Cavalry
the Lakota made up a lot of the American
Military for a long time in terms of
Cavalry during the 1800s so it's not
just blacks it's Indians too American
Indians were [__] huge in the
military yeah Bryce is talking about the
race thing it says uh my dad is white my
girl is white everyone intermixes
eventually Polynesians always say they
are pure Maui pure Samoan Etc yeah we
all mixed he's from New Zealand yeah New
Zealand uh we all have Asian and
European in us as well yeah it's just
kind of like we're not really it's just
it's drift it just seeps in
because you can't control people man and
the heart is what it is you meet
somebody you like them you you hook up
with them yeah it's just that's what
happens like I said you just you see a
person and you like them and you [__]
them and that's what happens and you
make babies yeah you know your your
girlfriend or boyfriend is going to be
the one you choose I mean not and you
choose them because you got in common
with them you're having fun with them it
doesn't really matter what race they are
yeah as long what matters is more you
have things in common Yeah well yeah
that's what I always thought yeah Mike
Barrett said Christopher Lee said his
favorite film he did was the Wicker man
yeah I've read that I love the [__]
wicker man if you like that movie go see
[__]
Midsummer CAU that cute little girl with
the [__] head the cute girl with the
head yeah she got I love her though
she's so cute he loves Florence look
like a little about her little her big
head she's a little girl with a big old
head like a little lollipop and she and
she uh she was [__] great in um
fighting with my family I got I got it
on DVD on Blu-ray and the extended
version is [__] is just as good as
the theatrical version better but if you
want a good feel-good movie about
Florida about a British goth girl who
becomes a wrestler see fighting with my
family true story and what's her name
again Paige Paige no no no the actress
Florence PE Florence Pew yeah she's just
a cute as a bug does a great job great
[__] Midsummer yeah and she's great in
Midsummer and she's great she's a tons
of [__] man she's like yeah she's in
tons of [__] nowaday
yeah but I mean I mean the Wicker man I
love folk horror the Wicker man probably
the best example I also loved blood on
Satan's claw which I feel like a lot of
people don't talk about but that was
also kind of another British folk horror
movie from around the same era that was
good too I don't know if it's still on
there but shutter used to have this
[__] great uh folkore documentary it
was like 4 hours long or something but I
sat there and watched the whole [__]
thing in one sitting and it was about
folk horror from like all around the
world it was so so good and there were
like so many movies in there that I
hadn't heard of that I needed to watch I
kind of want to watch it again but I
don't know if it's still on there or not
I have to
look I'm go to the
restroom yeah the bass Reeves thing
Oracle said it's a miniseries on
Paramount plus yeah it looked good comes
out in a couple weeks yeah the quality
looked fantastic I've been seeing it
YouTube has been sending me uh
advertisements commercials for it yeah
it it's right at my alley that [__]
looks good as [__] looks like a topnotch
western John chorus saw a 20-some kid in
a kind of a retr punk get up with a
resist imperialism and genocide settle
on just a good luck kid yeah I mean you
know you got to admire their enthusiasm
but you know we tried that didn't work
out so good but what are you gonna do
but see I don't know I was talking to my
brother about this a few weeks ago I was
just kind of like it's crazy to me I
mean we go
to you know goth clubs and we're still
into like C of old uh you know Punk and
Goth music and stuff and it's really
enlightening how many people
in their
20s are into that [__] and it's just I
don't think that would have
happened um in any previous generation
because it just seems
like I don't know man it's just like
even going back to the 50s like it was
not cool to like be into the same [__]
that like your old ass parents were into
like that's not cool but you know even
our generation was kind of like that too
we're just kind of like cuz our parents
were you know Boomers mostly and we we
were just kind of like yeah we don't
like that we don't want to do that you
know so it's just kind of like it's
weird that because of the Advent of the
internet and because all of the music is
just kind of out there and it's all kind
of I guess in a way it's kind of
equalized because you're not you know
it's just all out there like I said you
can just come across a song you don't
know necessarily when that [__] came out
you're just hearing it be like oh that's
cool you know what I mean it doesn't
occur to you that it's like that's
song's 50 years old or whatever so it's
kind of like it's it's weird how people
that young like come across the [__]
like I said we met we have a friend
named Nick and he's 21
22 we met him cuz we were at mannequin
and he was like full on and you could
tell he was a [__] baby you could
tell he was really young and he was like
full on death Rock he had like the whole
like [__] the Mohawk and it's like he
had a Christian death shirt on and it
was just like it was all old school and
I was just like holy [__] we we need to
see what that kid deal is because it's
like it's like he looks like a [__]
baby and it's like how did he get into
this stuff but it's like then we started
like talking to him and he was just like
oh my God he is like so into he's into
Christian death and Joy Division he just
loves like all that old [__] and it's
just like so so funny to me he loves
like old horror movies and all that you
talking about Nick oh Nick yeah cuz we
were just talking about
how how weird young people could
understand that like Yeah well yeah that
like people that young are like into the
same [__] like I said I don't think that
would have happened in previous
generations because it was like seen as
not to be into the same [__] that your
parents were into yeah but now it's just
kind of like I guess because the
internet made everything just available
all at the same time like I guess like
the the timeline or the times that
things came out are like not as
important anymore they kind of aren't I
it seems like what's important is H the
quality if the quality is good it should
rise to the top right and you can go
back and go oh man this is a great flick
man it's [__] 1933 check this [__]
out
because you got to look at our history
this is just the history of the world in
the same way you look at ancient history
because one day this will be ancient
history what do you give a [__] what
happened to something 45 ad and [__]
100 BC it didn't matter that's still
ancient history right but it's still a
Roman story yeah from your point of view
that's you know that's the context
that's how I look at it the what we're
talking about there is actually American
stories America could tell stories at
that at that point they were kind of
limited in some ways actually I think
the high point of American storytelling
were the 80s really um when it came
to tent pool type movies and I'm GNA
give it to [__]
Spielberg and
Lucas but with anything else man you
know directors have half lives as time
went on those guys weren't quite as good
if you ask
me um even Ridley Scott I love him as a
director a director not all of his [__]
is good some of his [__] is just like
like the one about the damn guys up at
the
[__] North Pole great movie but what
was the point of that movie it was it
ended up being kind of remember the guys
that were trapped up there with the
[__] Frozen in the ice with the boat
yeah and and the [__] Spirit of the
damn polar bear was up there I thought
it was a waste of time I thought he
could have done more with that but it
was a great quality movie it just it's
just weird you
know well he can't hit it out of the
ballpark every single time he could have
done a Blade Runner type thing
or
now I'm G sit here and [__] get on my
Soap Box uh oh Prometheus and I've said
this many times the origin Ridley
Scott's original plants for for
Prometheus were great but that studio
[__] him they [__] him royally about
changing the story to Prometheus to turn
it more more into an alien
sequel
dumb cuz the Prometheus story was
[__]
great so much of that script has leaked
over time what it was originally going
to
be just a [__] missed opportunity
because visually that movie was there it
had a great cast and everything and just
that they didn't do the story Scott
wanted to tell because he was going to
say anunaki
yeah and they didn't want to go that way
anunaki and neru and all that but that's
what it should have been well yeah I
mean they should have they kind of set
that up so they probably should have
gone in that direction instead but see
that's the thing it's just that
Hollywood Executives and they've always
been like this they've always been very
safe yeah I mean they're putting
millions of dollars up they want a a
large return on their investment so they
want something that that's going to
appeal to the largest possible audience
so if you and aour come to them with
some crazy ass idea that is untested
that they don't know if it's going to
work they're obviously going to try to
talk you out of that yeah part of the
anunaki story and what really turned
them off was the space Jesus
concept originally in the story it was
going to come out that the reason why
they were going to destroy us 2,000
years ago is because that they killed
Jesus and Jesus was actually a kid that
they raised on another planet to teach
people stuff which how great would that
have been right that he was actually an
alien right and then when we he was an
alien Ambassador and when we killed him
they said [__] it we're going to drop
this [__] like well screw you guys we
drop the black goo on them and reboot it
reboot the Gen the genetics that are
happening there starting again from
scratch right and the reason why they
did it is because they had lost the
ability to proc
create they couldn't they didn't have
gender of male and female so they were
trying to recre they they had
reengineered themselves to become
immortal but the price was as no
reproduction because they didn't want to
overpopulate and they couldn't re they
couldn't get the power of reproduction
back so they were trying to reproduce
themselves on other planets with the
with with with gender male and
female and they had done it did it on
many planets
but on planets where it would go
wrong where they couldn't make contact
with them and that they were living bad
and murdering each other and creating
technology and [__] like that they would
go there and try to set them straight
when they couldn't set them straight
they'd reboot him they hit him with
black goo and uh reboot Evolution that's
a [__] great
story that's a good
story but the religious connotations
they did they thought it would turn
people off that's too risky no that's
mean they don't like to take risks
because it's like they don't want to
offend anybody so it's like because it's
like well if we offend people they won't
come see me that's just that was just
dumb because but you know because that's
quite a horror move that's quite a
horror statement sure that Jesus was an
alien and it's not that I mean from my
point of view that's not that out there
because it fits with what they're saying
sure he came from the heavens and it's
not like there's not like kind of other
like weird like new Agy kind of [__]
like talking about that like I said like
all the an like conspiracy theories and
all that kind of stuff that's that's out
there in the it's not like he just
pulled that out his ass he's getting
that from somewhere yeah so yeah so I
don't see and I don't think in this day
and age I don't think that it would be
that controversial and even if it was
like who cares about the people that
would yeah be upset about that yeah and
the whole the the whole you know the
only the only the problem that they had
is that they didn't want the executives
didn't
want that that [__] engineer to say
we sent you an ambassador 2,000 years
ago and you killed him yeah you know
[__] that would have been great man
the humans are like oops oh yeah yeah
yeah my bad yeah we took him from here
and brought him to our world to [__]
train him and we send him back you
killed him so you got to go so that's
why we're mad yeah yeah yeah that have
been a great horror f it would that have
been great so you know see that's why I
kind of feel like if you're going to
make a movie like that it's like Indie
is the way to go yeah then you can just
make whatever the [__] you want John gor
said uh watched pansy's the tenant the
other night that's a great psycho black
comedy it do have yeah I love that
[__] movie We're fans I'm not like he
finds the tooth in the wall oh my God
that freaks me out so bad I don't know
why that freaks me out so bad and then
he looks AC he looks across into the
other building and the dude just
standing there and it's him it's him and
then he looks himself looking at him
with the [__] goggles oh that wigs me
out so bad like the tenant has
like I'm not a big fan of Roman palansky
as a person but it's just kind of like
his movies are the [__] bomb his
movies freak me the [__] out if you've
never seen repulsion yeah it's [__]
great the tenant is [__] great I love
the tenant you take off my head and what
do I see me in my head or me in my
body what right does my head to say that
it's me that's a [__] weird weird
[__] oh and Isabella Johnny is in
that [__] too and I have always contend
I think that Isabella Johnny is probably
one of the most beautiful women that
ever lived she is like stupid
beautiful yeah that chick was good
looking I didn't I mean she was a
beautiful beautiful well there were a
lot of beautiful women going back and if
you've never seen possession which she
is also and Sam Neil is also in that too
please see that because that's from 1982
I think that was one of the ones one of
the ones that growing up that I just
thought was hot as [__] too as a
teenager early teens 13 14 15
I would just [__] rock up over this
chick man I [__] L her soone had the
weirdest Father Of All Times [__]
Natasha kinsky I [__] thought she she
was so she yeah she's super I just
thought that girl was so [__] cute
from [__] cat people yeah man the
remake of cat people what's that Malcolm
McDow was in that too right yeah yeah
and I haven't seen it in a long time we
should see it again we should probably
did because we did the original cat
people from the' 40s cuz I think Oracle
mentioned that earlier I love the
original like the valtin one yeah um but
yeah they did a remake um with Natasha
kinsky and Malcolm McDowell in it and I
wouldn't mind rewatching that because I
remember liking that but
um yeah like yeah Natasha kinsky super
hot I'm like I'm thinking like Isabella
Johnny to me was always kind of
like her and Katherine denov were kind
of like I thought they were like the
most beautiful women on earth Alison
just goes the tooth yeah the god
there's just there's something to me
it's like look if I'm going to see a
horror movie I can watch Gore all day
long people getting their heads pulled
off and all orle night good night
Oracle and it's like and and I love all
that [__] I do but if something's gonna
scare me and give me nightmares it's
usually more subtle [__] and like stuff
like in the tenant oh and especially
stuff where people are in two places at
once I don't know why that freaks me out
so bad but it does CU David Lynch does
it a lot and breaks me out every single
[__] time but the scene in the tenant
yeah where he's like he finds this hole
in the wall and there's a [__] tooth
in there oh that freaks me out so bad
and then when he like looks across the
thing cuz he's in an apartment and they
like all the um apartments on the floor
like share a bathroom cuz it's Paris or
whatever and um and then he
sees himself in the bathroom like AC
that [__] wigs me the [__] I don't
know why John gor mentions how creepy
the hieroglyphs were in the bathroom
that's so [__] creepy why is that
creepy because there's not a lot of no
explanation well there's not a lot of
context I mean that really the only
context is that Simone the woman that
lived in the apartment before him that
jumped out the window and is in like
Traction in the hospital she was an
egyptologist right and she like had a
tooth missing too so that's why like
there was a tooth in the wall but they
never explain did she pull the tooth out
did someone else pull the tooth out what
happened like the the lack of context is
what's scary to me over time becomes
Simone then jumps out remember and he's
in trash and he yells St yeah oh man a
weird flick that is such a [__]
creepy and I was a kid watching that I
used to watch it over and over we used
to see it over and over again on [__]
like uh Cinemax and HBO they play that
[__] late
night and I'd be about 13 or 14 and have
a hard time understanding it trying to
put that movie together what it was but
it was creepy that movie is just it's so
I understand it more settling as an
adult I understand it a lot more now but
a lot of [__] clips from
that movie ended up in uh skinny puppy
songs yeah skinny puppy used a lot of
sound bites from
that [__] uh it's a creepy flick yeah
and I don't like palansky I think that
[__] is a scumbag I don't think he
deserves death or anything like that but
he was I mean because other people have
done worse I'm not saying he did was
good back yeah uh taking advantage of
young girls at parties and [__] back in
Hollywood Times although some people who
defend him say Well that girl was
[__] in all the parties doing that
with everybody but I mean that may be
the case but still you're a grown man
you're supposed to [__] know yeah
just like don't do that [__] how hard I
know I know back in the 60s and the 70s
they were more lenient with that [__]
but they were I know but still but you
know come on man I I really don't think
yeah like like I said if you're the
adult in the room uh you kind of have
the responsibility to be like nah yeah
you know what I mean like he was Roman
palansky he had his choice of women he
didn't know to go after these old
[__] 14-year-old girls that's what I
mean that's and I don't really get why
that
happens cuz it's there yeah I guess but
still it's just kind of like like I said
you're a grown man like get the [__]
over it like you don't need to do that
not not him there's women everywhere
yeah that that are your own agey had all
get in trouble that you won't get in
trouble for having sex with so just like
you know have a little bit of
forethought that's that's all I'm saying
in those days it was almost
never prosecuted they thought was
normal yeah it wasn't seen as a big a
deal right as it is nowadays but the
thing is though is that there's a lot of
people misunderstand the laws they think
that if it's under 18 it's illegal no
under 18 is illegal to take pictures of
them that would be child por each each
each state in each each state in this
country there's 50 of them has a law an
age of consent it's usually around 16
some states it's low it's like
14 some of them have statutory Clauses
like yeah you can have sex with her 14
but if you're eight years older than her
you can't do yeah there's like an age
kind of that would be
statory so
um the thing is though is that he wasn't
really accused of just having sex with
her he was having accused he was accused
of raping her right um that's my
understanding of it she filed a
complaining against him and she was
under I think she was
14 and I don't know how I don't know how
underage that was for California law at
that
time it may have been may have been the
age of consent I don't
know I don't know I had I had to go back
and i' have to look at like the
situation she might have been 14 right
that might have been actually legal in
California at that time but I would
think more likely 16 would have been
legal and plant wasn't that old at the
time 20s I think wasn't he late 20s well
this might have been was this before he
married Sharon Tate
right I thought I think it was before
yeah I thought it was I think it was
before but not not much long not no yeah
I don't think it was long before that
months or I can't remember the timeline
it was a long time ago you guys have
access to the internet you're not
working you can find the details maybe
drop in the comment section so I don't
remember I she may have been legal but
the the problem was is that there was
complaint of sexual
assault yeah which he had forced himself
on her if I remember correctly it
was rear entry wasn't it I thought so
too but like I said I'd have to look it
up yeah which yeah that's uh not cool to
put it lightly yeah Bryce said I've
never watched palansky him being a dirt
bag has put me off yeah I mean and
that's totally understand John gor said
a lot of rock stars and rock directors
were dirt bags they just didn't get
busted yeah yeah I mean pretty much any
I well I don't want to say all creative
people cuz some creative people are
lovely but a lot of people
um especially if they're real creative
and they have like a lot of money or
power and they're lauded um a lot of
them will use that to their advantage
and will let their worst instincts come
out let's let's say that so yeah you
can't part of the problem was Hollywood
that too Hollywood was a scene there was
a lot of parties going on at rich
people's
houses people from the studios were
there partying doing all kinds of [__]
some of those people were
underage some of those people were
underage at these
parties with their parents yeah and the
ories are going you know a lot of booze
a lot of drugs yeah yeah so um Tatum
O'Neal comes to mind just yeah a lot of
uh if I remember correctly Tatum monil
was in Hollywood origies at like 12 and
13 well didn't like Drew Barrymore like
say the same kind of thing well she was
mostly like just say like drinking and
drugs yeah and it'd be weird their like
parents would be with them also doing
it yeah which and rich people who are
famous and protected don't see them
especially back in this era of the movie
star before social media saw themselves
almost like
demigods they could do whatever they
wanted yeah that they were a separate
species which yeah which might have been
true cuz they I mean yeah a l
police right A lot of them did probably
get away with it well actually back in
the old days back in the Golden Age of
Hollywood the cops like people got
murdered yeah and people from the studio
would come to the scene before the cops
got there yeah and clean it up to clean
it up yeah of anything that this famous
person had that was like incriminating
yeah so it's just kind of like and the
cops would know yeah so it's like it's
not any different and honestly I think
it's a a lot better like people [__]
about it now but I think it's a lot
better like back in the [__] 20s 30s
40s holy crap like I said I even wrote
about a couple of cases in my book where
people got straight up [__] murdered
and all kind of [__] was covered up like
Studio exacts would come over and like
clean up the scene and then they call
the cops and they'd be like Oh okay
that's
cool it was just it was like that it was
just like understood you know what I
mean so yeah so I you know I'm not going
to say like I said Roman palansky is a
scumbag any body that does that to
anybody is this comeb back
but I don't know I I kind
of I don't necessarily want to support
them I don't want to like give any money
to them or anything like that but it's
just kind of
like I don't like
to I kind of like to separate the art
from the artist you know what I mean as
long as you're not really like giving
them any money or anything cuz he has
made some [__] cracking ass movies
the tenant Rosemary's Baby repulsion I
mean he's made some great [__] movies
yeah he sucks as a person but a lot of
people suck as a
person I mean if you couldn't watch
anything or read anything or look at any
paintings by people that were shitty
people there wouldn't be much left CU
most people are shitty people I hate to
say you know Danny Rowling said which
werewolf movie is better an American
Werewolf in London or silver bullet
American werewolf from in my opinion
Silver Bullet all day Silver Bullet is a
good movie I'm not going to I say
American werewolf but I'm going to still
give it to American World F but Silver
Bullet is good though so I'm not going
to like argue with you about it because
I really do like Silver Bullet it's a
different kind of movie it's a different
tone you know so I don't know it's like
hard for me to compare them Victor says
coherence has that doppelganger thing
going on I [__] love coherence if
you've never seen coherence it's I can't
remember the name of the director but he
made it in his house for some super low
amount of money the actors were all
people he didn't know them particularly
but he knew them because they were um
really good at
improv none of the actors knew each
other previous and he's basically like
well this is what your character is like
here's your daily brief like none of the
actors knew what was going on they
didn't see a script or anything like
that so they just kind of did it like d
today and the movie
is it's essentially all shot in one
house but it has like these big like
Cosmic implications and it's really
really well done that's how you do like
lowbudget horror SL SciFi really really
well it's a great concept it's a great
concept if you've never seen coherence
please see it it's really really good I
really liked it a
lot Mike Barrett said dog soldiers is a
great werewolf movie I agree um I
[__] love dog
soldiers uh we did a review of
that probably a year or two ago I want
to say when did we review dog soldiers a
long time ago yeah it was a while three
years that is one of the best werewolf
movies though I agree yeah it it's in
the spirit of the howling I would say
with the car with yeah yeah yeah but uh
really personally I got a hold and I
haven't seen a long time my favorite
werewolf movie overall would have been
how
that's a great [__] yeah kind of like
the howling I thought it had a
good um costumes story was good the
transformation scenes were of the time
but I still liked them it all practical
effects they had
uh that cute chick that was playing the
reporter I forgot her name Jenny would
remember who it
was the problem was is howling too
howling too sucks
and a lot and as far as I
remember all of the sequels
sucked I didn't re I didn't realize that
the sequel sucked until I saw him as
adults though that's the funny
thing I
mean when you're a kid you just kind of
accept
everything this kind of goes along with
the
scanners I love scanners scanners one
and I remember liking scanners 2 I went
back and watch Saw scanners 2 it was a
[__] piece of [__] man I I was like
man I liked this movie I can't [__]
believe it it was [__]
terrible see what be
saying yeah Sebastian said the same
thing to
how
okay man I'm [__] way
behind I was going to say that I'm
pretty sure please correct me if I'm
wrong yeah but the guy that did the
special effects on the howling yeah was
Rob botin the same guy that did the
effects on the thing oh did yeah okay
prob because Rick Baker was supposed to
do the howling yeah but then he went to
do American Werewolf in London the
famous transformation scene so Rob
botin went and did the howling and then
he did the thing a year later yeah so I
I yeah the f I remember I need I don't
own the howling I need to buy
it that's a great [__] movie I
remember liking it what I
remember seeing the
howling and remember the female werewolf
the chick in Black yep I [__] Lov
that chick as a little boy as a boy she
said she man I thought that chick was so
[__] hot she had a whole nude scene
and she turned I get it and there was I
think that was the beginning of my goth
fetish yeah cuz she was that was like
she was kind of like I would call her
kind of like
kind of [__] uh Fleetwood Mac version
of [__] goth you know
she what was that chick's name [__]
from from she looks a little bit like um
Fleetwood ma oh my God why did I the way
she dressed was that chick's name
[__] now you made me forget yeah yeah
the singer from Fleetwood Mac yeah I
know talk yeah uh she kind of Stevie
Nicks yeah she kind of had the Stevie
Nicks witchy kind of outfit right yeah
but she kind of had it was black she had
a long black hair and uh I just remember
being real [__] sexual it's real sexy
and that I think that was kind of like
one of the goth kind of
chicks that yeah kind of was like yeah
the black thing with the black hair and
the kind of like the [__] Sinister
sexuality you know [__] yeah I think
that might have been you still like that
kind ofu I still like it that might I
think that might have been been the
beginning of it m
but I also like female vampires he still
likes the bad girls I like bad girls
yeah I don't want to live with a bad
girl but I like bad girls just same
thing with chicks with the bad guy thing
bad boy yeah bad boy is fun you don't
you don't want to hang out with you want
to like live with them or you know let
them like give them access to your bank
account no you're going to get in
trouble you know or let them drive your
car right or nothing you going to get in
trouble
I'm kind of like that but I'm
trustworthy I've think I've never [__]
I never [__] up your bank account or
your car or anything and I well you're
you're well you're kind of an
interesting case yeah because you're
kind of like what would be considered a
bad boy I guess yeah but you also have
like a very deep underlying sense of
Honor yeah well discipline where yeah
yeah where you would never cuz I have
never really thought that you would [__]
me over no you know what I mean no I
have a sense of I yeah I never really
got that sense from you that you would
do anything like that cuz you just I
mean you'll do some crazy [__] but it's
like you you you have a very you have a
very strict moral code where you're just
kind of like hey if you're my friend or
something like that like I'm not going
to [__] you over no I don't betray
friends like you don't do that kind of
stuff you just don't so I guess you can
say I was kind of like the Han Solo
version of Bad Boy where you're not I do
bad [__] but I'm not bad to people
that's a good way of putting it yeah
you're like you're like the Han Solo but
like in real life yeah cuz you're kind
of like you're kind of like an [__]
but like not cuz Han Solo was kind of an
[__] yeah but a lot of that's bra but
like a lovable ass yeah and yeah and
that's kind of what your [__] is cuz a
lot of your [__] like is like kind of
over the top like you said bravado but I
don't believe it yeah a lot of it you're
just joking yeah and you're just [__]
around yeah so but like deep down you're
like actually like a really good person
like you have like a really strict like
I don't know what is strict that's not
the word I want to use but like a really
like developed like moral code yeah I
never thought that you would yeah yeah
like [__] me over or anything like that
I just never got that
sense I mean I've gotten that sense from
other people but Jenny knows me I will
break laws to defend friends because
friends come before all that [__]
although it depends on [__] what it
is that's happened you know what I mean
like I'm not going to cover for somebody
else's [__] murder just cuz you're my
friend you murdered some chick [__] I
know I ain't covering for you but I
wouldn't either because that's not the
right thing to do my code you know what
I mean right it's like you killed an
innocent person so yeah not we're not
talking about that kind of [__] but uh
no I don't really care if it's legal or
not I just care whether or not it's
going to protect my friends you know
what I mean yeah within reason within
reason like I said right you murder
somebody in Cold Blood and then be like
hey help me hide the body I'm like no
I'm reporting you
sorry well I think it would depend it
was depending on who it was [__]
murdered in Cold Blood he was a threat
to a bunch of other people I might look
the other way yeah then maybe I might if
you're just some chick and you murdered
in Cold Blood Cuz you liked her titties
no [__] you well yeah we're definitely
reporting it yeah yeah we don't care how
close a friend you are right yeah yeah
so like I said you have a
pretty you have a a pretty well uh you
know
delineated moral code yeah and it's not
anything new I think it's just ancient
I'm just doing what dudes have been
doing I think for a long time you know
so and as far as I know I just I don't I
don't recall you ever really [__] me
over I don't think you've ever [__] me
over not that I can no I protect friends
no I protect friends or destroy enemies
that's [__] that's that was the
programming from day which I mean is
kind of rare like a lot of people will
kind of [__] people or just do [__]
behind their back or if they can get
away with something they'll do it it's
like oh they you know they won't find
out about it or something like that but
you don't really seem I'm not into that
you're not really into that into that
kind of thing I don't see that as power
I see that as weakness yeah I mean I do
too Cru that type of Cruelty is weakness
yeah betrayal is weakness yeah I agree
you're right yeah I agree you only
betray evil which is probably why we
like each other because we kind
of because we kind of have the same kind
of thing going on even that we're kind
of coming at things from like different
ends of political spectrums or whatever
but it's just like we have the same I
don't know we have a very similar kind
of moral code I feel like yeah the
political spectrum is [__] crazy
especially right now but in
general it's two different
manifestations of the same thing there's
two different ways of protecting things
yeah that's all it is yeah my way of
protecting things might not be your way
of protecting things I have a different
version of it but no I have very good
instincts towards security and what will
work and what won't work because I
default to the
mean I know that humans are a certain
way that human nature isn't that good so
I kind of DB everything down because
that tends to
work no plan [__] survives the face
of the enemy everything you plan for no
it doesn't really work out that way so
in my experience the experience
everybody that served with me is for
Generations was to dumb everything down
that tended to work in general anything
complicated
or highly elevated in thinking now that
breaks down in the face of evil you know
things can things have to be right but
things have to be strong at the same
time or they will not survive in the
phase of
evil I'm getting too drunk to explain it
it's all right we get it yeah Bryce says
um I agree with statutory laws like an
18 and a 16-year-old is all good in my
view yeah that's fine but a 30-year-old
and a 14-year-old is damn creepy yeah I
think there should definitely
be um you know you have to kind of look
at each Cas on a case-by Case basis cuz
like you said an 18-year-old with a
16-year- old girlfriend that's not weird
to me that's what the statuto laws were
mostly about clear in that is that that
they're still
kids but it delineates what this this
guy is unreasonably older than this
young girl yeah yeah like I understand
that I don't it's an adult like and it's
they're much older then yeah that's a
little bit I understand that but I I
like to like I said to dumb it down more
there should
be what they're worried about is is that
they don't want to send 17-year-old kids
to jail for [__] around with
15-year-old girls well I don't think
they should either right that's the
thing because 17y olds and 15y olds are
both in high school they're both in high
school they're both in high school and
they could reasonably be dating and I
don't think anyone would think that was
weird that's what the statutory laws
were for they weren't
really per se to It's usually the
statutory laws came in because the age
of consent was kind of high in that
state like it might have been
16 but the chick's 14 or 15 but the
dude's only 15 you know what I mean
these are kids you know that's what I
mean that's why you have to kind of look
because I have had cases where and this
happened like several years ago and this
is in Florida where we heard about
somebody that we kind of knew like well
not you cuz I think this is before I met
you but um that was on oh my God they're
on the you know sex offender registry or
whatever yeah so we were like holy [__]
so we looked it up and we found out why
they were on the sexual offender
registry was because for that reason
like they had dated somebody like when
they were 18 or something that was like
15 or 16 yeah stupid and it was and I
was just like that's not yeah a thing
like why should that be a thing school
together yeah you're technically both in
high school or one just got out of high
school and that one still in high school
that's not weird at all so it's like I
don't really get it's easier to me for
me I I believe in the states that just
say that there's an age of consent law
that if a girl's 15 or 16 she can
consent to sex with a with with an
adult that's a good way to say but the
thing about it though is that well
there's nuances because what if if you
know this is an older man that's like in
a position of authority over you like a
teacher or no no no no no those same
States also have things where teachers
cannot have sex with the children well
yeah so that that's another that's
another so that's a separate that's
separate
issue um yeah you want to make laws to
where then there's kind of like the high
school and middle school teachers or
whatever can't [__] with the students
well I mean that should be a given and
it's sad that we need a law to kind of
say that but cuz obviously but well a
lot of the [__] that you hear about a
15-year-old boy with a [__]
25-year-old teacher okay which there was
a lot of that going on for a while you
know well yeah I heard about that a lot
of that is that actually the boy for
that state was of legal consent but she
was the teacher yeah which makes it
illegal well yeah because like I said
and that's and I don't have a problem
with that because like I said if someone
is a position of authority over you then
that raises the issue of coercion of
coercion um you know or you know
blackmail or there's various other
things that could be raised like I said
it would be the same thing if you were a
teenager and the like and you worked at
McDonald's for example and this was your
manager yeah um it's kind of the same
issue it's like you don't want to get
fired or you don't want to fail the
class or whatever so it's like you kind
of felt coerced into the situation
because you didn't want the
repercussions so it's like you didn't
really consent to it had they're not
been these strings attached you wouldn't
have had sex with this person I think
it's more reasonable and more realistic
if a 16-year-old across the board can
give
consent you
know uh some some State say can give
consent to an adult
okay which would be somebody of 19 or 18
or
19 that makes more sense because if a
guy at 18 can be drafted and go to war a
girl at 16 could have sex or a boy can
have sex at 16 like I said I don't
really have a problem the only problem I
have like I said if it's somebody that's
like way Rel or somebody that's like in
a in a position of power over you that
isn't a in a is in a position of like
yeah kind of flexing that authority over
yeah obviously there's ISS you could
probably
uh you want to make sure that the
teachers aren't in there being pred PR
dating on them that's that's what that's
what you did I will say when I was in
high school and I'm not going to mention
any names mostly because I can't
remember them but when I was in high
school um one of the teachers at the
school a male um his wife had actually
been one of his students previously and
he married her later on well ganther
he's a cop and he was we grew up
together and Michigan went to high
school together and he'll [__] we talked
about it earlier before no we knew of
sever
things going went on a lot it went on a
lot and I it was normal I was going to
say too that was normal though also when
I was in high school and I'm again I'm
not mentioning any names one of our
teachers who I actually really liked I
thought he was a cool dude um but I
found out later that he had tried to he
was married but he had tried to get with
a friend of mine who was 16 and he was
40s yeah uh she was not down she was
just kind of like bro no um you know
what I mean but he was like totally in
love with her and uh I only found about
out about that like after like
graduation and it kind of bummed me out
because I had really liked
him gr there's knew a teacher and uh I
thought he was a cool guy actually he
was old Stoner guy he's in his 20s
probably mid
20s and he was dating one of the girls
there she was a hottie maybe about 178
they he'd go out to the [__] Park Lot
smoke weed and [__] come back and do a
class he'd be baked you know yeah we had
a we didn't really think we didn't think
it was a big deal he was just like you
know yeah no nobody really thought about
it they just like whatever he's high as
sh when I was in Brazil in the
international school there was a couple
there I'm not going to name their names
they were a married couple they were
young though
20s in an open relationship and both of
them were dating students both the guy
and a
girl but they were like
seniors you know what I mean they didn't
go after little kids they were going
after like 18 year
olds and they were you know 25 26 I mean
I kind of feel like once they graduated
they're fair game they weren't graduated
they were in there they were seniors I
feel like if you have your [__] together
if you have a like I like look okay if
you're a teacher and some teachers are
young like we had some teachers that
were only in their 20s yeah and if you
have a crush on an 18-year-old girl
that's not weird That's Not Unusual
nothing like that and it's you know it's
not weird the other way around either
but I would say just for the sake of
your
job um you just for Optics just wait
until they
graduate yeah that was you like them
that much you can wait it wasn't
happening in Brazil because a lot of
times when they graduated they went back
to the United States or whatever country
that they went to but they were just a
uh young
couple I thought they were all right and
they would go to the clubs we'd see them
at the clubs people like we were at the
clubs you high school no in Brazil there
was no drinking age not really if you
could afford to come in and you look
like you were at least 15 or 16 a lot of
European count F too or were when I was
there yeah they didn't really care about
that kind of [__] like they have laws
but they they're just like close enough
you're like you're all right and then
and uh but no they'd be at the clubs and
[__] you know they were both dating
students of opposite Sexes they were and
they were just
a a [__] couple with they were in an
open relationship
they
whatever and the kids I want to say kids
but the the seniors that were dating
them knew everything they were like they
were they were all about
it who's going to tell them no well I
think at that age a few months later I
was in the Army like I said once you're
getting to like 17 18 yeah I don't
really have a problem with it anymore as
long as no one's being like coerced into
anything as long as everybody know is on
the same page about what's going on it
was another era and it was also another
country I don't really have a problem it
was another era it was another country
it was another class of people these
were rich kids that school was not just
for rich people you know I was only in
there because I was [__] state
department and [__] later on my mom
remarried a rich guy that owned a dental
manufacturing facility there in Brazil
that's why he lived down there yeah
called Skol Pao famous [__] school
all the president's kids went there of
Brazil the king of Brazil went to school
there I knew him his name is Louise and
he was just some [__] loser [__]
the class that he was technically the
king of Brazil but they got they'
overthrown the
monarchy and
uh it was you can go online and look at
Skol God water to S Pao it's [__] a
fantastic [__] school it was I B
International baloran School I got out
of there man [__] College was nothing
I got bored with college that's that's
school was [__] Advanced very
Advanced I liked it very
expensive but like I said in those days
my family made a lot of
money
um so it happens more
frequently at the higher levels of
[__] society I mean they don't really
see that these these rules don't apply
to
them they're more they're more uh
liberal with with with that [__] well I
mean people that have a lot of money
they have the experience of just being
getting able to get away with stuff yeah
so it's just like well yeah I'll just be
able to get away with stuff in
perpetuity so they just do whatever yeah
you know what I mean and the cops can't
come after them they own the police
that's what I mean like what are the
cops going to do they can just pay well
even if they get arrested they just pay
to get out $3 million on here you go
they never get arrested that's what I
mean even if they did yeah they got the
money to get out there's no complaints
and the cops are afraid to arrest them
if you got money you can pretty much do
anything rich kids and rich people just
are that they do whatever they want yep
yeah that's the same here too yeah Mike
Barrett said what about Ginger Snaps
that is also that that's a great [__]
mov one of my favorite movies yeah Tom
loves that movie yeah and I like the
sequel too yeah the sequels are also
good yeah um the first Ginger Snaps is
the best one but the sequels are also
good yeah easily one of the the best
werewolf
movies um good night Allison thank you
for hanging out with
us uh Victor says Most states have Romeo
and Juliet laws for that kind of thing
yeah oh Victor says okay here we go age
of consent in the
US 31 states are
16 eight states are 17 and 11 states are
18 that actually surprises me because I
thought some were
younger I thought some states like
[__] Al Alabama or Mississippi or
something would maybe be
14 but maybe not maybe not nowadays I
haven't checked in a long time
admittedly John gor said if you can get
behind the wheel of a potential death
machine you should probably be able to
consent yeah I kind of feel like you
have to be consistent
with the responsibility that you're
giving to people if you're letting
people drive a car if you're letting
people vote if you're letting people
join the military then having them not
with which is kind of why I feel like
it's dumb and I know why they did it um
that they raised the drinking age to 21
and they did that like quite a while
back I know why they did it uh it's
just it seems a little
inconsistent if you're going to let
everybody do this stuff oh we've decided
that you're an adult at 18 now but you
can't drink for three more years that
seems a little weird to me seems a
little weird Victor says we used to hang
out I'm going to tell this to top with
our 2 25-year-old teacher when I was in
high school he drink with us sleep over
our houses and was sleeping with a
couple of girl students oh my God yeah
we um what you talk about I missed it I
knew a teacher like that what did he say
Victor says we used to hang out with our
25-year-old teacher when I was in high
school yeah he drink with us sleep over
to our houses and was sleeping with a
couple of girl students he ended up
joining the Air Force L yeah yeah um
yeah our school was like that too we had
a we had one teacher like that that was
he was was close to our age he was early
20s yeah so it wasn't that weird and he
was into the same [__] as we were into
today if that [__] would hit the news it
would be a [__] Scandal like [__] you
talking about but it in those days back
then it was just like okay yeah that's
kind of cool yeah he's the teacher come
on man get high well like I said it's
kind of like as far as age goes like
look if you difference if you were 17 or
18 and we like out and you met somebody
that was like 22 yeah and you had a lot
in common and you started dating no one
would B an eyelash yeah but the fact
that they're a teacher and it's just
that situation yeah that makes it a
little weird but other than that I just
like I don't really have a problem with
I don't I I wouldn't have a problem with
it if it was outside of that context is
what I'm saying yeah cuz a few years
later you'd all be in the club anyway
sure that's what I'm saying yeah and
you'd all be considered to be the same
age by Society yeah because it's not
that much of a difference Bryce says I
knew of a teacher in high school she
banged all of the male students and got
fired over it it was a big Scandal and
she served time she was like 40
something okay and some of the students
were as young as 13 yeah okay that's
[__] up yeah she had a little fetish
going she absolutely should have gone to
prison for that because that is messed
up that's messed up she had a little
fetish going on 13 is far under it's a
little bit I'm gonna say it's a little
bit you know I'm going to be a little
bit different I'm going say it's a
little different with male students I
mean [__] it is but it's still if I
was 30 and some chick who was she was
hot and she was a 40 and she wanted to
go i' be I'd be all about it if you were
30 no if she she if I was 13 and she was
[__] 40 and I [__] thought she was
hot I'd be all about it I'd be like in
heav well yeah but 13-year-old boys are
really P kind of different than a
13-year-old girl cuz there's there's
a you know what I mean you our society
is you're trying to protect the
virginity of these young protect them
from predatory men they don't protect
boys from predatory women
because the every boy will Dive Right
into that [__] they're like y yeah I've
been waiting for this hell yeah bu it's
still kind of [__] up though because
you're still kind of it's weird it's
exploiting them well it's weird when
it's weird looking at it from the
position of an adult but no if I was 13
14 15 at that time no I'd I'd have been
all about it yeah I'd be like okay yeah
we could to do this well see but that's
what I'm saying it's like yeah most of
the time most 13-year-old
girls uh if a 40-year-old teacher like
try to SC [__] out of them right yeah no
help yeah boys are a little bit
different but that's what I mean yeah it
but yeah it's different the way they're
coming at it but that doesn't mean that
it's not still exploitative or
manipulative because it is you know what
I
mean but but it is kind of a different
situation I guess well just in the way
that they're coming at it I guess well
we're built a little bit different guys
are built a little bit different yeah I
think that woman is odd that would be
that's a weird that's a weird woman that
does that but no I'm just saying if I if
she was hot and she was 40 and I was
like 13 or 14 in she's [__] put in
the moves be jump on it I'd be like yeah
yeah back in those days I remember my
hormones were [__] D I can see that
well probably most teenage boys yeah I'd
be like [__] you are gorgeous baby D
we're gonna do this walk me through this
like your tiny 13 yeah so it's not quite
the same you know what I mean
um is it
exploitative I wouldn't have thought so
at the time I mean from the pro from the
perspective of an adult it is cuz I was
[__] fantasized about but 13-year-old
boys are idiots 13-year-old girls are
idiots 14 I was fantasizing about some
[__] like that sure I get that I was I
was looking at women at six going God
her titties are [__] great well you
know no it's just different for boys I
think a little bit even though your your
your hormones are not you haven't gone
through P your hormones aren't raging
but even even when I was young I was
like man these women are [__] so [__]
fine but it was different it was a
little bit it wasn't as visceral it
wasn't as sexual what age did you go
through puberty not you hadn't G through
puberty at 13 about 12 13 oh okay 13 I
was going to say no seven you haven't
gone through puberty oh you oh you said
seven I no I'd be like six or seven
looking at go God her titties are
[__] so great man I think I was 11 or
12 I I had just turned 12 or was about
to turn 12 no I started going through it
probably about 12 12:13 around that
time and I remember when the [__]
[__] it happened all at once it see
it seemed like it built up and then all
of a sudden it was just like damn there
was a huge difference in a period of
like about two months your [__] [__]
like quadruples in size in a period of
like [__] two months interesting and
then all of a sudden you're shooting
live rounds and [__] you're like God
damn and where is this coming from what
is happening to me knew but I was just
like damn I knew what it was but I was
just going like that was fast you know
it that was fast I don't really remember
how like two months the transformation
took like two months I kind of feel like
mine was like much slower but I don't
know it's like maybe it was it was a
long time ago so I don't really remember
no you go from like [__] like this to
like that in [__] two months yeah
yeah I've heard that it does come on
quickly for like dudes but yeah yeah
it's not as well like I said it's not as
overt
for like obviously you get your period
and stuff but which
is not fun right you guys get to have a
bigger dick we just get to start yeah
bleeding out our nether regions oh yeah
and then and then you're like and the
aggression goes that's I was saying I
was like at
13 you had a hot 40-year-old [__]
come at me I'd have been all about it be
like yeah oh hell yeah [__] you know
we're going to do this you
know you walk me through this woman cuz
we're going [__] i' have tried to man
up like a [__] so this is this
is going to be your like Mentor yeah so
sexual Mentor yeah so it's very
different it's a lot it's a lot
different that's a you know what I mean
John gor yeah it is yeah John gor said
and this is another thing that I wonder
yeah he's like is a [__] worth it
getting fired getting sent up getting
kicked out of your country sometimes it
is obviously yeah because some people
still do it yeah it's it seems to me
that irregardless of whether the
13-year-old boy would be into it CU you
know doubtless a lot of them would be
yeah yeah but the thing about it is that
you were a grown person grown man grown
woman whatever the case yeah it ain't
right um is this worth is it really
worth it no you
could do any number of other things to
satisfy those urges Tom showed me
something very disturbing because we
were talking about getting a sex doll
for for the videos for the show and for
the videos and stuff because we thought
that would be a fun like addition
because we could both do like as a prop
so we were thinking about so we some
cool ones out there too yeah they do
have some cool we action figure like
super we were thinking about do getting
like an elf one cuz I don't want one
that looks like a person Tom doesn't
want he's like I don't want one that
looks like a person that's weird but
it's we want one that looks kind of like
a Fantastical creature
yeah or a superhero with [__] a
vampire or an elf or something they have
some cute Vamp but you can assemble one
out of bodies and heads [__] so so we
were looking at once and then he's like
I saw some [__] the other day it's like
you need to see this yeah so he shows me
this site scared me man there's a site
which I guess I don't know how I feel
about this so there's a site that makes
sex dolls but they are we're so getting
demonetized no um no no you got word
this right that way it made all
different kinds it did yeah one of the
sections was was called minis
minis The Minis were a lot cheaper and
they were about 3 feet tall but they
were women they had brass in the same
proportions of a women of woman but then
slowly as you go through the catalog
they get flatter and flatter and younger
and younger until they're children you
know what we're talking about yeah yeah
and you're like what the [__] a Jen
look at this [__] he I'm very
uncomfortable with this [__] and he
showed me the stuff and it's yeah I was
very uncomfortable they look like little
dolls little girl dolls and [__] I was
kind of like I was like okay I said I I
don't know how I feel about this because
it's like on the one hand this is really
creeping me out and my skin is crawling
yeah on the other hand if a dude that
had those proclivities could buy one of
these and not um didd the [__] terrorize
actual people yeah then that then that's
a societal good yeah so I started
thinking about the I'm ambivalent about
the whole situ but it's creepy to look
at they're creepy yeah I saw that [__]
and I was like wow yeah he's like look
at how [__] I'm like oh yeah and
they're like so creepy
young yeah all right and they look real
they do and uh I was going Jenny look at
that [__] man that's some [__] freaky
[__] this is what we do out that's some
[__] I say I'm not really I'm not C
with that [__] and she's like no I ain't
comfortable with that [__] either and
and I started getting me thinking I was
like remember that [__] Spielberg
movie AI where they had the [__]
robot a little boy that was supposed to
be the surrogate child of a woman like
well her kid died so she bought this
robot to be a substitute kid I started
thinking like once they have those AI
[__] sex bots it's not going to be
substitute children it's going to be
[__] sex children that's what they're
going to be doing but I guess I guess uh
Spielberg didn't want to [__] go that
route well he doesn't want to make the
move like no one's going to go watch a
movie about that right because they had
Jude Law playing a full grown male sex
bot he was a pro male prostitute yeah
he's like a cool ass character I liked
in that movie he could change his hair
and he could be as swaave as a
[__] could be whatever you want
and then like he'd come on and he'd say
some [__] awesome [__] to some chick
love a lot by the way and I don't know
what company he worked for cuz I don't
know why he needed money but they were
paying him so I guess it I guess the the
cryptocurrency or whatever went to
whoever company had made him which I
don't know why would a why would a robot
be hooking himself what did he because
he wasn't doing anything with the money
so I guess they just put him out there
like taxi cabs yeah that's what he was
to make money for the company sure and
that's what he was doing was his name
Joe I think or something um his name Joe
oh I can't remember now it's been a long
time I saw that movie in the theater
yeah he could change his hair color he
could change his [__] face he could
do he wanted to become and he'd put the
moves on these women and get
them they didn't see him like they
didn't show him like hitting up gay men
though which I feel like would be like
the larger market he could he could
probably do that too just that I guess
so did they show that in the movie no
but he could probably do that maybe that
would have been too controversial well
they were female versions of him also
remember Jane I think her name is Jane
you saw her in the hotel we need to
watch that again I haven't seen that for
a really long time yeah
but I was thinking about that and I was
going like yeah that a AI movie [__]
beating around a bush it wouldn't be a
surrogate child it would be a [__]
lover is what they would be yeah
selling child man weird [__] yeah it was
pretty weird so like the Stu he was
showing me was like pretty weird and I
was just kind of like I was like I don't
know like I'm weirded out by the fact
that they make them but in a way it's
just kind of like maybe it's better that
they make them
you know like I said if it keeps like at
least one PDF file from violating a real
person then that's like a good that's
like a that's good right what they're
still weird though what I said if it
keeps at least one PDF file from
violating a real person and that's
probably good
right but still it's still weird to look
at it's weird yeah it's still pry weird
to look at cuz we look we were were just
looking at adult like elves with big
titties come on why did we get into this
yeah we just want an elf with big
titties there's not a female market for
it because they'll sell all
these they'll make all these different
female dolls and there'll be like one
male doll and I I would think maybe
there might be a gay market for it too
but one of them was called
leonitis he had like a gladiator yeah
yeah that was really the only one they
had though he he didn't he didn't look
and yeah he looked kind of skinny for
like I said it's really weird and well
you can tell like what the intended
Market is like who buys this kind of
stuff because honestly there are very
very few male sex dolls the ones that
they have are either just like a
disembodied chest with a erect dick on
it yeah which are a little weird um or
like I said they just have like one
token one yeah like all the other ones
are women or trans
yeah like they had some kind of Fooda
type ones kind of yeah they had a Fooda
kit to convert one into a now I did like
that I was just kind of like that might
be another thing we could look into we
want this maybe convertible yeah but you
know just for so we could have options
but
um like you know 99.9% of them were
female what I did think was cool about
the uh the
dolls is that uh and it was the site
that was selling
them they were selling fantasy dolls
they they said these aren't just
something that you you know basically
used for sexual purposes they're also
good really good
decorations and uh people dress them up
as their favorite
characters and they showed some vampires
you know and superheroes and whatever so
it's kind of like a lifelike statue and
they do look really cool nice faces yeah
cuz you could just like put that in your
house in the corner and nobody would
think oh put it back here on the show oh
it's like they [__] that
yeah they dress them up and they pose
them and [__] kind of like a life-size
action
figure you know they do have some really
nice ones they're exp they're not cheap
though I'm going to say you're going to
spend at least a grand like I said if
we're going to get one cuz like I said
they're very
expensive um I don't know I I wouldn't
want a mail one
that's just it's not super appealing to
me I don't know why I guess that's kind
of why like women don't buy that kind of
[__] we just don't well just the Torso
is good enough for the for the seene and
even that like what the [__] it's kind
of creepy yeah some people are like what
the [__] you that's kind of creepy when
you make video to
sell adult video there's a whole process
of verification to verify the identity
of somebody that's in the video that's
in the video see they have to like take
a picture next to their driver's license
it's a whole right and then and then of
course you
have you have to pay that
performer uh and you know I got contacts
in the local scene here you know I could
get any of the locals really through my
friends but they they want
money but if you but the thing is though
is that you can't play any any videos
you make with them on a lot of the
profiles that we have or a lot of the
platforms that were on like streammate
and streammate she can't even have me in
any the vide in the videos he can and I
can stream there but I can't be in the
videos but he can't be in the
videos for whatever reason right but so
if you wanted to sell say a lesbian
scene off that video it couldn't be a
real
girl because I don't think you can get
her
approved unless she was already unless
she was already approved on that
approved on that platform just real
sticklers about their real well they
don't want to get their ass in trouble
they don't want to get sued like I get
it like you know what I mean there is
like a lot of uh you know the the
industry is right for exploitation and
right you know there's trafficking
concerns and stuff like that so they are
very um strict yeah about stuff now if
they're already a member you can do a
video with them and just like tag them
in it and it's fine right oh if they're
a member already if they're yeah yeah
yeah well what's funny is I'm a member
in she can't tag me under any videos
yeah it doesn't right even though I can
stream there live but it would be good
to have something like that at hand
because real quick if we were ever
streaming and you needed to do a quick
lesbian type scene or threesome scene
we'd have a
dummy yeah like you don't have to pay
her she doesn't have to be you have to
pay her and it's just she'd just lay
there and do you whatever we want it and
uh they got girls selling videos of that
and they got guys that are into that
it's like a special
anything is a specialty or a kink sure
anything yeah stuff you wouldn't even
think of yeah Victor said whoa I just
looked up my old teacher on Facebook the
one he was talking about the one that
used to sleep over people's houses and
stuff and he's married to one of the
students he was sleeping with okay they
have three kids okay yeah well I mean at
least well he did write by her I guess
they got married he's like they made
it probably a good couple Bryce was
saying I remember all the boys at the
time talking about the 40-year-old that
was banging the 13-year-old students
yeah uh were disappointed she didn't get
to them yeah he's like I personally was
more interested in her husband
[Laughter]
haha that's the thing like I said and
it's not the same Dynamic the other way
around but you're still
exploiting what is essentially a child
so like just don't do that just don't do
that there's really no reason to there's
no reason
to I don't I really don't understand
why someone with that much to lose you
presumably at that stage of your life
have uh a career and perhaps a family
and a house and stuff like that
and I really don't know why you would
want to throw that away just to bang a
13-year-old I really can't see how that
would be worth it for any I really don't
I mean you know
I understand other people are not me but
I just don't get it I don't get it yeah
and Tammy said I can't even imagine
finding a 13-year-old attractive see I
can't either I just
don't that's a kid I mean that's a child
I don't
really I don't know I don't get it I
don't get
it like it's
not it's really not something that has
ever occurred to me like yeah when I was
13 other 13year old olds were probably
attractive to me but when I'm an adult I
was like that I never even thought about
it what's that like when you're an adult
like other like 13-year-olds being
attractive to
you the only thing that would have
bothered me if I went through that I'm
like 13 or 14 the 40 the 30s something
year old
teacher I think she's
hot what would have upset me is if I
wasn't the only one if she was doing it
to a bunch of i' have gotten jealous
like [__] you don't love
me that's the that's the only one cuz I
would have been you know what I mean I'd
have been [__] possessive probably I
would think
so probably not at first kids that age
tend to be not probably not at first
that have been like you kind well kids
that age are very um self centered yeah
i' have been like you're kind of like
well it's not just me oh they the center
of the universe you [__] you that's
probably what would happened
yeah John gor said women used to be
magical creatures to me when I was young
I think that's true of a lot of dudes
which is very funny we're not magical at
all yeah we watched Gotham By Gast like
we loved it I you guess you didn't yeah
we um talked about it a little bit like
um on the early part of the show yeah
that I think we' watched like a lot of
animated Batman yeah over the last few
days and that's our favorite one yeah
that's been our favorite like that was
excellent I really like that a lot
underneath that one I would put Dracula
vers vers or Batman versus Dracula
underneath that I'd probably put the
Doom that came to Gotham the love craf
one no I would put
um uh bat ninja Batman Ninja Batman yeah
and then I put the Gotham Doom that came
to
Gotham we saw a couple other ones we
couldn't get through like 20 30 minutes
of it like the Halloween one I thought
long Halloween long Halloween uh I
thought it was kind of stale and then
Batman year One I thought it was pretty
stale but there's a lot of stuff there
to choose from so I know there's more
good I know there's more good stuff in
there yeah we have HBO Max so there's
like a lot of animated Batman on there
I'm really starting to gravitate towards
maybe watching some um Justice League
because that'll have Superman and Wonder
Woman and all that in there maybe so
some of that's probably pretty good too
we should probably do that also yeah and
I want to see Lego Batman Lego movies
that's yeah I want to see the Batman
Lego cuz Legos always kind of has a fun
playful we did see one of the Lego
movies in the theater but it wasn't a
Batman one I think the I think Lego
Batman was in it but like as a cam it
was one where it had everybody in it
yeah it was everybody I liked it I
thought it was fun I did too it was fun
I kind of wish I was high when I was
watching it but because I was I was I
was an adult with in a normal frame of
mind and I'm like yeah okay this is fun
but you know come on but if I was high
i' probably more into it but uh Lego
Batman I got a feeling will probably be
pretty good you got to learn to be
naturally High yeah yeah just shed your
adultness yeah is what I'm saying uh
Macky Ma just arrived hello how are you
uh just watched five nights Five Nights
at Freddy's so how was that
because I know that it's based on the
video games I saw the trailers it looks
pretty cool however you know a couple
years back we had Wily's Wonderland
which was essentially like a I guess a
ripoff of that
so is it different than that is it
better than that is it worth watching
let me know because I do kind of want to
see it it looked pretty good but I'm
kind of like well I already saw Wily's
Wonderland so is this going to be more
of the same yeah or I don't know no it's
not going to be the same it's could to
be different Tammy said be high on life
LOL yeah all right I got to pee again go
ahead talk about something she want me
to just talk about something talk about
something see if people talk usually
have problem
other see what everybody's talking
about
okay yeah um as far as the as far as the
animated superhero stuff
goes I'm going to go through some of
that Batman try to find the best
stuff and then I want to go through like
the animated Superman stuff because I
I'm a super I'm a Superman fan too I
like I love red
Sun so if you guys have any uh any
suggestions on animated Superman go
ahead and drop that in the comment
section I liked Red Sun which is like
parallel universe Batman or Superman
what happens if Superman were to land a
Soviet Union I thought that was [__]
great probably would like justice
league so if you guys have any uh
recommendations go a and drop that in
the comment section about
what oh that's better damn oh uh Danny
says why do people call the Air Force a
chair force chair because they're
sitting at offices on a chair they're
not doing [__] Air
Force [__]
very high class compared to the
army they got much better facilities the
foods real good it's very civilized it's
like a regular job in the time that I
was in they had cute girls in the Air
Force lots of them too and they weren't
hookers Army girls were all hookers when
I was there were half of them they were
[__] hookers they're
trashy um some like what we talking
about yeah yeah [__]
I met a female exci
agent and uh she asked me what I that's
a long story she was asking what I
thought about females in the military
and then more I got from nowhere she
didn't think that women should even be
in the
military and her job was is to break up
Pro prostitution rings in the
Army what happens is is there are young
girls coming into the
army they show up in an army unit
they're outnumbered 20 or 30 to one to
dudes and these are very average looking
women and on average [__] the dudes
that they're surrounded with are hotter
so it's kind of like a kid in a candy
store and they're living around all
these dudes who they think are hot they
start sleeping with
them other girls that have been there
longer than them are like why are you
sleeping with all these dudes and not
charging them so then they start
charging them all right and they make
more or about the same off charging
these dudes than they do on their
military
paycheck I mean it's so bad out at Fort
Campbell one time I was down there at uh
the park we used to hang out with at me
and all the guys that rode
motorcycles A van pulled up one time it
had three girls in
it and they were in there turning tricks
in the park and they were all Army girls
that's how bad it was back in the 90s so
I can imagine how bad it is now and they
were kind they were trying to to like
clamp down on it but Army girls were
hookers when I was
there lot of I would say half of them
not say all of them and not just the
Enlisted the milit the the the officers
too it was just a bad scene I don't I
didn't I didn't [__] serve with
females I was in all male units they
were infantry units at that time we
didn't have integrated Army and
integrated infantry type Shield type
deal back in
then but in those days I
thought if you were going to have
females in the military they had to be
in segregated units all female
units they were in the in units and
[__] dudes to try to get promoted and
everything and and then as soon as
deployment would happen they'd get
pregnant so they didn't have to
go and they and pregnancy wouldn't kick
them out of the military they just get
more money
so then they go back to the barracks
they give them better housing and then
they had kids so then ended up being
welfare and whenever you needed to
deploy them to go to war they get
pregnant
again so I thought it was just me but
that CID agent chick said the same thing
she's like no there shouldn't be any
women in the Army at least not in not in
non-segregated units these aren't normal
women they come
from lower in income
families never been away from
home and as soon as they get in there
those other girls are a terrible
influence on
them so I had a different view than a
lot of people today I don't know if it's
changed if it's changed it's probably
worse today probably
worse all that [__] was going on even
back in the 90s
they were Prosecuting it in some
ways but also they were bending over
backwards to [__] hide it because it
was kind of a they didn't want the media
to know about
it all talking about Five Nights at
Freddy's uh mackim Max said it was good
but they kept it
PG13 Willy's Wonderland is much more fun
because of Nicholas Cage I agree I
really liked that movie actually
um Danny Rowling said Batman the red
hood is really good we looked at yeah
that's on hbm Max 2 that was one of the
ones that we were thinking about we were
thinking about watching it so we
probably watch that one over the next
I'm they're starting to respond yeah so
red hood we didn't we didn't
like the Halloween one the long
Halloween long Halloween didn't make a
good impression in the first 20 minutes
and uh Batman year One didn't make a
good impression it was too
stale so go ahead and give us some
uh uh some recommendations and we'll
we'll check them out we did like ninja
Batman Ninja Batman was great we guys
got to finish it yeah because I kind of
fell asleep at the end yeah we only got
like 20 minutes left on it Macky Max
said if they made Five Nights at
Freddy's and rated uh M or R I guess it
would be better I think Nicholas Cage
would be a perfect fit for Five Nights
at Freddy's some people love the movie
but I enjoyed willly Wonderland
more yeah I I never like when they kind
of want to make a horror movie and they
just want to make a PG-13 I get that
they're trying to you know appeal to as
wide an audience as possible for the
money
but you're just cutting the balls off it
you're just cutting the balls off it why
do you want to do that to yourself I
don't really
know um Victor said I would have join I
should have joined the Navy that would
have been hot as [__] Navy I heard the
Navy being referred to as the love boat
all the time [__] uh well now you're
just making him want to join yeah The
Love Boat yeah they just go in there
yeah Victor said that Navy recruitment
video made me gay yeah they just [__]
yeah gays and straight people just on
the boat
[__] I mean okay my dad was na sounds
but that was Old Navy I I [__] the Davy
nobody was [__] back then no not my
dad time they weren't [__] they
didn't [__] until they got to Port my
dad was telling me stories he go
man oh I want to hear
this just one time so we pull my dad was
on the USS
Yorktown it was a reconditioned World
War II aircraft carrier it got kind of
partially sunk and then they fixed it
they made it bigger again he was an
electrician on the York
toown he was on the Yorktown when he met
my mom actually they were writing to
each
other say yes
so so we pull in I'm in the
Philippines and I'm in the bar and I
make it out with this chick she's fine
as [__] in the bartender goes no no no
no no no no lady boy lady boy he go what
the [__] is a lady boy boy
boy because I reach down and sure enough
big old like in The Crying Game spoiler
I said what' you do said nothing I just
said get out
of for all I know that my dad are you
sure your dad for all I know my dad hit
for all I know my dad
hit he probably hit I kind of feel like
that happened they just like oh lady boy
I just told them to go away but they're
like no I totally did that [__] no my
dad's not that
dumb he's just like whatever all right
all right lady boy that's pretty funny
so he told he said that was in the
Philippines yeah yeah [__] sailor's
taverns and just Seaman [__] running
around there [__] doing that
[__] Bryce said I would get pregnant to
avoid going to war if I could LOL they
do they do they all come down pregnant
soon as deployment starts happening they
all get Knocked Up I mean pregnancy and
all war babies all that fun War babies
yeah yeah war time happens and then all
of a sudden they're all pregnant because
they don't want to go Macky Max says
start a petition Tom singing the
loveboat theme the
loveboat [__] I haven't I haven't heard
that song I Can't yeah I can't remember
the
words it's cheesy as [__] the love you
know what's hilarious the only version
of the loveboat theme that I can
remember is a version that they made a
joke about on MST yeah so which are not
the real words so I can't even remember
what the like the jokey words were but I
can't remember what the real words were
I used to kind of my grandmother used to
watch The Love Boat so I've seen a bunch
of episodes of it when I was yeah I was
a little kid but I mean I kind of
remember it I kind of remember it but it
was
just what I don't know was it as sleazy
as I remember yeah it was kind of it was
kind ofy right no I don't know I kind of
feel like the Whole Decade of the 70s
was sleazy everything was just like
[__] everything seemed sleazy
whenever I watched movies from the 70s
like like jalon movies or old horror
movies from back then I'm like man
everything was just so
sleazy everything was sleazy Danny's
saying that they should make the service
mandatory no they shouldn't shouldn't be
mandatory shouldn't be mandatory because
the United States really shouldn't have
a military not not in the way that it is
now because if you give them a
professional military or a big military
what they'll do is they'll just they'll
just project it into other countries and
then grift off of it because they make
so much money through through the
military-industrial complex and they
[__] lose every war they get into all
of them okay because it's not they're
not real wars of Defense what what the
United States needs is needs a Defense
Force which is a military that stays
here of professionals all right um yeah
it can have a Navy to maybe protect
trade routes and stuff but the idea of
the United States being a global hegemon
and the [__] policemen of the world
that's an A A thinking of a [__]
bygone era because the other countries
have caught up or surpassed us in many
ways so we just can't run around telling
other people how to live and try to be
the [__] big kid on the Block those
days are over
um you got India China and [__]
Russia man they're they're [__]
powerhouses they got a lot more people
they're tough they don't worry about
casualties they don't have the same
needs that we have so they just need to
the American Empire is coming to an end
those days are over and you just can't
protect all these allies like Korea and
is Israel and [__] Japan and all this
[__] that we have around the world you
just can't do it you can't protect them
all and what they're going to do is
they're going to attack them all
simultaneously it's happening right now
and will be spread too
thinly that was all a bygone era the
outside world is not Savages they're nor
they're modern people they can take care
of their own things they have their own
cultures we're not here to tell them how
to live and that's what the United
States has been doing for a long time
and they're resentful of it now just
that the average American's been
insulated through its propaganda Network
through we call the news they're telling
you that the outside world loves us and
that we're fair and that we're the uh
that that we are stabilizing the world
and [__] no quite the opposite we're
very unfair we're like
gangsters uh we [__] squeeze [__]
foreign countries to get them to do what
we want uh they hate and resent us for
it and uh we're no longer technological
Superior to them and we're not
militarily Superior to them this
is Russia is a world class [__] Army
right now they are just badass and if we
were to fight them right now we'd lose
we'd lose bigger than [__] they're just
not telling you that Pentagon knows
though I've seen the papers I saw the
Pentagon reports they said that we
couldn't fight Russia we'd
lose so they're the leader
now and that's just the way history runs
and you can't be the leader of the world
if you don't have an IND if you don't if
you're not an industrial Powerhouse and
that's China and
Russia danan rling said Tom check out
the episode of Batman Beyond titled The
Winning Edge it's got old Bane and new
Bane AKA his P the winning okay Batman
and Beyond that's that's that's that's
in Seasons seon That's a series and I
think there's also a movie about Batman
and Beyond so I don't know which one
you're talking about what what well
probably like he says it's in the it's
in season one in the series is it in
season one or season two I don't know he
said the episode of Batman Beyond okay
you can find it all right I mean I could
find it on HB yeah I don't know where to
look there's several seasons of there
I'll find it okay all you got to do is
search the episode title name okay
what's it called again The Winning Edge
oh The Winning Edge right yeah it would
be very easy to find
good it'll be fine yeah the series cuz
they have I'm pretty sure they have the
whole series
on uh Max as well I keep calling it HBO
Max it's just called Max now but
whatever
whatever all right so are you ready to
yeah go and shut it down get off of here
yeah because you seem to have quieted
down yep all right so hopefully you guys
have a good weekend uh the weekend
before Halloween so I don't know if you
guys are going to like Halloween parties
and stuff like that we're probably going
to one tomorrow right we'll see how it
goes but you know have fun be safe
wherever it is you go thank you for
stopping by and chatting with us thank
you for Super Chat and we will see you
guys again for a movie review on Monday
I don't know what movie it's going to be
we'll find out the same time as you will
uh so yeah thanks everybody for coming
by and we will see you guys again on
Monday good night